Hey All right, I just realized I'm I just realized oh wait a
minute I just realized I forgot to set up some stuff We have
to set stuff up no for my end.
I meant my end.
I need to have you guys do stuff for no No, no, I mean like
I need to have you guys on my screen.
I really I forgot about that There was something I forgot
about Let me do the discord overlay It's like, I use Fuggy.
No, crap.
I'm just too lazy now.
Yeah, no, I think, yeah.
If I wasn't a streamer, I'd be lazy too.
And I was like, wait a minute.
I knew something was missing on my screen.
Something very important.
Wait, where the fuck is this guy?
All right, here you go.
Hey, where are you?
You're not on my screen.
Where is this?
Sorry, very professional chat, I know.
This is...
We're starting off very strong here.
All right, there's you.
You're going to be far away from me, Tempo.
So, hello, everybody.
I hope Tempo is not too loud.
I hope he is not too loud, guys.
Am I not too loud?
I don't know, actually.
Your mic is like, you're like in a very empty room.
That's what...
Your room has definitely has no soundproofing done.
My mic has four things.
It has the Olympic circle thingy.
What the fuck does that mean?
It has just a circle.
It has something that looks like a fortune cookie.
Oh, wait, do you have a blue Yeti?
Yeah.
Okay, yeah, I was gonna say that sounds like a blue Yeti
shit right there.
So what do I do?
Fortune cookie, a circle, or the Olympic thing?
Sound people, what should he do?
I, okay.
I'm not like a sound person.
What the fuck are you?
Why would I know this?
It seems like you're a streamer I thought I thought I
thought you know.
Yeah, I'm a streamer that outsources to other people on
things that I don't know Like sounds being one of them.
I I'm just here to choose things and look pretty.
That's really all I do Like Do you think I know anything
about sound?
Oh, you want fortune cookie everyone says fortune cookie.
I am on a fortune cookie.
Why the fuck do you sound like you're in an Do you have any
like like I have stuff in my room do you have like any oh it
feels like your room is like super empty That's what it
sounds like Door is open Bro, I don't know does it actually
does it actually?
Yeah, he sounds like you're it sounds like you're in the
bathroom
Someone was like pad your wall That's true.
I was gonna say that too.
I was gonna say like push shit around your room door door is
closed does that does that change anything i guess it like
improved a little bit it's like a little bit better but it's
still it's so weird it sounds like yeah it sounds like
you're literally in a bathroom that's really it my room has
stuff in it yeah but you need stuff on your walls oh there's
nothing on the walls yeah that's why you need stuff on your
walls that's why posters that yeah your your fans sent yeah
yeah yeah yeah i'll send you a little wait wait you should
all the acoustic doki posters yeah yeah yeah it'll give you
better soundproofing you should i'll give you a list of
artists to buy from and then okay doki artists if you have
any doki prints send up on etsy or anything let me know and
i'll make tempo buy them with his own money He has a TSM
money, which isn't a lot, but like...
Sorry, I should say that.
But if you get paid very well, Temple...
TSM money, which is it?
You get paid very well, Temple, for what you do.
Oh, no.
Don't worry.
I was spreading misinformation earlier, guys.
Don't put this on any eSport report.
news that a VTuber just exposed pay a roll.
Guys, it was just a joke.
I swear.
I am so warmed up.
Now I can't wait to not hit any of these shots in the actual
game.
It's like, it's like Wigs that's such a long interview.
I think so.
Where's Oh my god.
I like how like Whig is like The name of the tournament But
Greek is Cassie Wait Greek is Cassie Yeah Yeah Wait isn't he
Is he playing?
Wait Oh Why the fuck did it say Greek?
Oh it says geek lounge I thought that said Greek That would
be so funny though Okay got it That would have been so funny
though if like greek was the one casting it i should have
casted it he should have casted it you should have it would
have been so funny it would have been really funny also guys
how is um how was tempo should i raise him up or should i
keep him this volume i don't know if sound guy is awake
right now i'm still in the bathroom so it's okay yeah tempo
sounds good playing from the toilet yeah he is so we do
pretty badly to be fair there's a lot of things against us
right now um we're worried that we're in the list of teams
that's not it uh it's an announcement i think guys i just
want you guys to know um i'm gonna talk about this again
when wick joins us but like um our team technically consists
of two plat players and a gold player because wait temple
you're gold right who's the gold player i'm in plat you're
in plat oh three plat wait no is wiggin gold or plat we said
he was in plat it's three plat players oh it's three plat
players okay it's okay I put two plats in the golds for to
increase engagement okay wiggin's the gold right it looks
better when I have a gold in my title because people are
like whoa and a gold player um but let me go derank myself
here yeah I mean that would be easy where am I actually I'm
very close to derank Okay, it's full of views.
Anyway, um, so our team technically consists of three plat
players.
And, um, the thing is that...
If you guys watch the drafting stage on Wing Stream, um, I
was on the list and it listed me as plat 4.
Because technically...
Technically, I had plat 4 as Doki Bird.
so so i was listed as platform so no one so like people were
like who the fuck is this platform shitter um yeah so i
committed the greatest heist of all time convincing staff i
was platform
i did say no i did right i was like oh masters but i play
like a plat player so that's why i literally said okay the
reason why i was in platform was because they were like
what's your rank and i was like well i got masters in the
last was it five seasons but i played like a plat player and
then they're like okay give us your like tracker thing And
apparently the tracker lists your average rank overall.
And my average rank overall as Doki is Platte.
I got away with it.
Yeah!
I can't believe it.
How does she keep getting away with this?
How does she keep doing this?
Oh my god.
It's so fucking crazy.
Somebody stop her!
Change the badges.
Oh, don't worry.
Don't worry, guys.
Don't worry.
I'm way ahead of you.
So, I improved.
Don't worry, guys.
I thought of this, too.
I thought of it as well.
I do.
I have one singular plat badge.
I just need you guys to know that.
All of the badges, I actually have one.
one singular plat badge in okay here let me show you guys um
where's the badges look we're gonna ignore that but look at
that my my one singular plat badge right here we're gonna
ignore the other chat we're gonna ignore the other ones
we're gonna look at the ones that matter right now all right
the ones that matter welcome back hey welcome back thanks
dude so how was the interview it was good they said uh hope
you win i just started laughing oh because we're totally
gonna win right yeah for sure for sure wait wait what about
now what do you mean what do you mean does it still sound
like i'm in a bathroom yes you yeah definitely does a little
bit wait i just realized oh my god they like locked out some
of the badges because they haven't fixed it yet oh no really
i just realized that because i was like wait i am missing
badges what the fuck my plat badges of course that's what
i'm saying i'm missing yeah yeah my plat badges because like
for some reason on my count i only have one I'm a multiple
plat player.
I have a lot of bronze badges because I was really bad at
one point.
And then I improved the plat.
At one point.
Yeah.
Specifically, there's one point where you were bad.
No, no.
I literally have like six plus bronze badges.
Do you actually?
I've heard you have flags, though.
I can't walk out.
I do.
Okay, we would look.
How do I go see my badges?
Check out my stream right now.
Check it out.
Don't worry.
I thought of this too.
If people were like, wait, she's not plat.
don't worry i am glad because i put my badges on i'm all the
matters you got the badge on accounts we'll be sharing the
first usable legends here soon okay cool all right nice i
didn't mean to cut you off you're streaming on you're
streaming on twitch i was like yeah of course it's twitch
rivals why would i be streaming i don't know i don't know
it's literally twitch rivals all right let me put you whoa
add you on the screen here Yeah, you got some nice bronze
badges.
Yeah, you like it?
Yeah, yeah, you know, I improved as a gamer because like I
went from bronze supply I'm at my peak.
I'm at my peak right now.
Yeah All right, Anita apparently raised up.
It's all right.
I'm not gonna be the last person joining in anyway I can
like.
Okay, wait.
We have our comp here.
List of legends from Pap 1.
Okay.
Fuse, Mad Maggie, Horizon, Revenant, Bloodhound, Rampart,
Watson, or Gibraltar?
Wait, can you repeat that?
That's a lot of people.
Assault.
Okay.
Assault is going to be Fuse, Maggie.
Oh, I can read it.
Skirmisher is going to be Horizon, Revenant, Recon's going
to be Bloodhound, Controller is going to be Rampart, Watson,
and then the last one is Gibraltar Spirit.
like a a ring reader so we need somebody to read the ring
and we're gonna survive here that's what people are probably
gonna do they're probably gonna go horizon blood yeah you
know all the pros are gonna take okay run everything down
yeah wig our captain yeah you're gonna run everything down
yeah right right right oh hell no i'm the player i'm playing
it says it says captains pred pro are you trying to say
you're not professional did you lie on your resume you lied
on your resume my linkedin was a complete fucking lie i
shouldn't even be here in the first place fake it till you
make it i guess wait so are you playing for you no we need
we need somebody for rink or for controlling if tempo wants
to play views i'll play bloodhound i'll take the hell yeah
it's fine okay that's great and then i guess i'll I'll play
Watson then.
So we're playing Watson, Bloodhound Fuse?
Fuck it, dude.
Lock me in.
I'm so down.
We did so much to read the ring.
I mean, no, I agree.
Yeah, you're right.
You're right.
I know who's up.
And we're starting up on World's Edge.
So I put Geyser.
So we're Geyser.
I'm sorry.
That's not the best POI.
We have.
You gave us Geyser?
I don't.
I know.
I panic.
You gave us Geyser.
You're literally the fucking headliner.
You can request for any fucking POI.
And then we have tempo that can kick off any pro player off
the scrims if they try to contest us.
I know, I got scared.
I said abuse your power, not be a bitch.
Oh, but I'm always a bitch, man.
I'm always a bitch, bro.
Oh, I was always a bitch.
What happened to you, man?
What happened?
I've been this way.
We had to go back to childhood.
I don't know.
What?
I was so emotional trauma.
Whoa.
how long ago how long ago did I become a little yeah I
become a little fucking I mean geysers realistically geysers
not awful it is no it's pretty no it's pretty no you guys
are just coping now does the flying thingy still go through
geyser what what the what the what thing the ball thingy the
evac what the ball what is the ball flying ball the drone
that flies with the ball what why why is that why am I
forgetting what the drone the loot tick are you talking the
loot balls guys I'm just not bottom five that's my goal what
do you mean not bottom five oh my God he watches apex every
day and said the No, the loot tick is the thing.
The cargo bot.
Yeah.
The loot tick is the thing with the legs.
But he said the ball thingies.
You know, he said as if it's like something we fucking take
like a fucking the towers.
Oh my God.
Okay.
The lobby's open.
I'm heading in.
We're gonna we're gonna cycle.
Not bottom five.
I'm actually not gonna use charge rifle and no one will no
one will run out of it.
i'm running bomba for sure let's go okay how good are you
with the sentinel bro can we just run three snipers and just
go somewhere high and then just try and snipe people and get
kills that way and just make everyone angry okay we just we
the way to get to that area is that we have to make sure we
don't die to travel there first that's the we have to make
sure no valk is going to be our crutch here we're we have no
Remember, we need three Evac Towers.
Well, last time we played, well, actually, no, we didn't
play.
But last time, you know, that's when you were in Tempo
played.
Yeah, I would say that we had Valk because we literally
needed it.
Now we don't have it.
But no one else has Valk, too.
Without Valk or an Evac Tower.
Okay, so at this point, we just got to hope RNG our way.
Wait, wait, wait, you have connections to staff, right?
Can they...
towers in front of us.
Yeah.
Like, like, like, like my chat.
A Greek just came to my room and said, if tempo kills me,
I'm pulling the fucking ethernet cable.
So tempo, if you kill him, bro, my internet goes out.
Just know where his internet goes out too.
He fucks over his phone.
No, he just gotta come in mine and pull mine.
But he's a wait, what?
But you can go over to his room and pull his as well.
Yeah, I can't pull out.
I can't pull out how's internet.
There is peace.
You can pull.
And how tell how tell how.
No one's.
the house alone everyone's oh okay i can't pull out anyone's
internet no you wait oh wait how wait does any tsm member
live with you they all do but no one's here no no but you
can be like just log in just log in on his computer and then
it'll just disconnect him no no no threaten their pcs i'm
gonna i'm gonna install destroy 2009 on their pc if you kill
me okay to be fair i out but you can do that it's true but
keep this mad for their pcs they threaten their pcs you
literally have they're like babies right now that's like the
way to go hold their pcs hostage exactly so in my chest that
hold their pcs hostage for for first place oh my god we're
cooking my god someone i'm so happy i didn't listen to any
of that and just i literally come back to we're cooking so i
just know that was an absolute show of words that i
shouldn't have heard no we're disgusting about how tempo
should hold tsm pcs for hostage so be like your pc is going
to get ransomware if you kill us oh holy bro they're gonna
be so scared they wouldn't want
we're gonna do so well guys i not bottom five that's all i
ask for bottom five no no no way it's bottom five there's no
way there's no way and if we do get bottom five the system
hated us for we were too good to play their games no listen
i'm gonna tell you right now you guys listen I have the
right are you sipping something you're laughing no I'm just
laughing at you I was like this is gonna be a serious thing
now here listen I I can get us where we need to be okay okay
how we just that I don't know yet we're gonna figure out
okay okay I thought I thought you figured it out we don't
have a valk a valk was really easy for me to get us to where
we need to be but i'm telling you if we get there i think
tempo is gonna pop off i'm serious here too i'm not lying
okay how much you want to bet we don't have to bet anymore
no no no no no no no i want to know where your money is like
how much you want to bet i'll bet you a second blended
subway sandwich we didn't do the first one i can't trust you
on that you didn't do it either i was waiting for you i was
waiting for you technically i'm not i'm free from that
already
Oh no.
And technically, I'll prove Dokey Bird didn't promise.
Dokey Bird didn't promise a blended subway.
I'm just saying.
I'll give you five subs that Tebow gets.
Well, actually, how many kills though?
You know what I mean?
Like how many kills?
That's how much you believe in them.
Five subs.
That's how much.
His life is worth five subs.
That's like how many dollars?
That's like...
Don't gaslight me.
You're playing on his downfall.
You're saying he's so bad.
No, I wouldn't know how much.
Unless you believe in him, but clearly you don't believe in
him enough if it's worth five subs.
All right.
Yeah, you couldn't be more right.
100%.
Yeah.
No offense, Temple.
I love your death.
I'm like, I'm not going to sit here and sell you.
He's gonna get like 10 kills.
I think Temple gets like five in six games.
I can't believe.
I can't believe he's like, if he gets a kill, it's gonna be
on a pro player.
So you try to say that his pro player kills aren't even
worth more than one sub per kill.
It's not even worth one.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
only only allowed legends is fusing mad maggie horizon what
revenant oh they're going they're going revenant okay yeah
yeah yeah okay bro you mean yeah you're trying to say tempo
is worth like 25 and kills correct bro if i had to pay tempo
to be on my team for two hours i'd pay him 25 oh what are
the what are the odds someone ends up with negative points
today who's to then
Wait, say it again?
Oh, yeah.
Wait, I didn't say that.
Who the fuck is that guy?
Who the fuck?
I don't know who the fuck Silenna is.
What a fucking bump.
Yeah, I'm Doki.
Yeah, what are you talking about?
It's my first time being Doki.
Yeah.
Okay, five subs.
Okay.
Tempo does, wait, wait.
What was the deal?
If Tempo gets, like, a one kill, it's five subs.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
You're making.
Holy shit.
I'm so.
Wait, one kill, five subs?
Yeah.
No, no, don't keep me.
I didn't say that.
I can get a hundred subs here.
Yeah, okay, okay.
If Tempo gets one kill, you have to gift me and Tempo five
subs each.
Oh, my God.
Imagine, imagine Destroyer actually gets in his lobby.
Also, like, also if he doesn't, you have to gift me five
subs.
All right, down.
That's why I'll deal.
Okay.
Deal.
All right.
I don't know how I always get routed in these things with
you, but it just matters.
It's fine.
Yeah.
No, you didn't.
Of course you did it.
You do it every time.
You're so good at it.
Because you're such a little bitch.
That's insane to say.
How am I a little bitch, bro?
I'm a bitch for believing in my friends.
Now you don't agree that you're a little bitch.
You literally told me you've been a little bitch since you
were done.
I'm believing in my friends.
See?
You literally told me.
You literally told me you've been a little bitch since you
were in sixth grade.
since you were six and now you're not no no actually today's
the day i changed i'm not a little bit today's the day you
changed after giving us geyser as a drop spot today's the
day you changed hey listen i got command center that's
pretty fucking good all right for the next map all right i
got that maybe i am still a little bitch holy shit hey
listen all i'm saying i'm gonna do this ready look at me
look at me yeah banned from 20.
oh fuck i spelled 20 wrong oh fyi at knock yeah let him know
the knock is knocks thinking about where free kills are now
i guarantee you okay just be like licking his lips just be
like if you kill us wick isn't gonna watch part of your team
they might be thankful for that oh no you will you will
watch their team that didn't do the you kill us wick's gonna
watch no one no one should drop on us i told them no they
don't get any dc restart that they do oh my god you're a
cheese dude nice you're cheese hold same hostage huge tempo
fuse nice oh yeah hold them hostage only free skin i got who
am i going again um what how about bloodhound yeah yeah yeah
and you're going watch yeah yeah i'm going watson i'm We're
already, we didn't get negative five.
So that's, that's good.
That's good.
Yeah, we're doing it.
We're doing.
If someone goes negative, we, we have to be mean to them.
But that's actually just like, we have to be mean to them.
We have to be mean.
Yeah.
Just spam, who, who's negative five right now?
Who are we restarting for?
You've got to be mean.
Here we go.
We, we got this.
I can't beat you, I'm messy.
Okay.
Wow.
All right.
Where, where am I landing?
Passing to the little bitch, I guess, dude.
Yeah.
The little bitch who's captain.
yeah yeah well baby we're trying to build up your confidence
that's why i'm giving you jump master you just call me a
bitch like 40 times yes but if you cry now you can build it
back up yeah run it down yeah what doesn't kill you makes
you stronger you're so right yeah words will never hurt me
exactly only in high school exactly where they really hurt
high school hopefully the zones cost we're not getting a
contested right there's no way to contest i'm gonna leave in
the game it's like what the do you want geyser for it's
literally the shittiest drop ever i should know no name i'm
just gonna go through tunnel i'm gonna take my i'll go down
here okay we have no beacon yeah we're off to a good start
we could go to overlooking at it wait there's gents killing
more oh it's not fucking uh anonymous mode yeah it's okay i
don't know i'm missing oh don't restart it we're fine that's
one less team to worry about true actually i'll tell them to
put on for the next game to be honest all right they didn't
have it on during what's it called either the asia festival
right uh i don't remember i don't think it's common in in to
have it on for yeah for asia isn't it big i think you're
right because like oh it's been a while since i played
tournaments yeah we can grab two charge rifles vick you
already have one do not listen to the dark comments in your
mind be the most annoying team in the game do not listen i
don't have a backpack bro okay we're off to a really really
good start no no no no it's just it means you're gonna grab
a you get purple backpack later on in life yeah yeah yeah
next game next game you'll get a okay Okay, we'll take this.
Okay, guys, thank God we don't have to...
There's no armors left on the floor because I don't think we
were ever going to find armors in Geyser.
No, we were probably going to get just triple white anyway.
Yeah.
There's no difference now.
The Geyser's like...
Yeah, it's pretty bad.
It's not like awful.
No, it's fucking awful.
What do you mean?
Yeah, it's pretty awful.
Well, if the little drone is flying by, it's okay.
Yeah, you can shoot the drone.
we have do we have a bulky yeah no no no why would you think
we have a little the little drone did not come this way who
didn't pick a three times tempo it's really it's really cute
that you think we'll have anything it's okay wait where do
we go i chill i'm trying to i'm trying to think we gotta we
gotta craft up craft the bat real quick i've okay you guys
have i'm gonna craft i did i'm gonna craft the battery too
we have four bats i can craft an extra bat for you let me
okay i'm gonna hit this raven and just see where people are
going so we're not getting right now wait they might be
riding that tunnel i think i might have saw someone one
second okay because i'm crafting this if i get shot we're
gonna we're gonna we're gonna we're gonna chill in i still
have a backpack it's crazy here here's a bat nice pretty
sure i saw a white uh white backpack or maybe maybe it's
kind of faster faster all right we should try to rotate to
where a beacon is where is beacon well big mods probably
still over there so i don't know if i can go that way oh
thank you see you look at that siphons pretty i mean we
could just rotate a siphon but There might be multiple
squads rotating in that way.
Hmm.
No, there's no save inside.
Let's just start walking up.
I believe in you.
I don't have any of that tower.
Is anyone in?
Uh, nope.
Nope.
We are in an awful spot for our rotations.
There's a pack right there.
I don't know if...
All right.
Who's going to get it?
Look at all of us.
Let's start moving up.
Wait.
There's like two.
Yeah, let's do that.
All right.
How are we still on?
We're very, we're very not so good.
right now i'm gonna go get it because all right i'm gonna
cover you i'm watching with the charge rifle yeah yeah
watching that way fences behind us okay i'm dead guys that's
really good try that's fine i'm so if anyone comes one is
blue armored that's okay we're so fine they're dropping down
guys they're dropping that they're heading to that area i
forgot what that area is okay i got an r301 free okay yeah
yeah him up tempo tempo go tempo go i'm dead we're gonna
reload i'm I was missing.
Are they?
Okay.
Wait, are they?
Are they already crossed over that?
Are they in the building?
I don't know.
They ran back into Siphon.
Okay.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna just come up and scan because we should
try to get one of these buildings and move in from there.
I'm gonna scan one sec.
I should.
We're right behind you.
Yeah, come up.
Come up.
Nice job, Cambo.
Twist his fucking.
Oh my God, Tim was doing it.
You know, I have 12.
I have 12 nades.
If we can just trap someone somewhere, I can just, I can
just go.
Let's shit loose.
I mean, I have a gold R301, realistically.
No matter how bad I am.
13 made.
We wanna keep moving in a little bit though, cause I don't
see anyone posting up here at all.
We wanna keep moving.
It's all gonna be like near a harvester zone.
We're gonna keep moving.
I'm just gonna keep scanning so you don't get ratted on.
All right, I'm right behind you.
Guys, we're not 20th.
No, that's huge for us.
We're not 20th.
We're making waves.
Oh my God, it was Keon.
It was fucking Keon there.
Siphon?
Ah, what?
No, no, no, there was, there was, there was.
I think how cool.
oh my god I don't think this whole side's looted though yeah
that makes me definitely think it's towards the definitely
this is not this is not zoom I have 12 20 shield cells
alright we need to go middle we need to take this gondola
cross it comes back over and I'll scan we have oh there's a
ring cancel yeah that's where we're gonna go hit there was a
team here 30 seconds ago yeah getting the coast I mean car
what the house we're gonna get in the house over here if
there's a team here just stay on the gondola I'm not kidding
yeah yeah I can stick with my arc all right about which one
okay someone protect me while i do the ring concert yeah
this is extremely sketch but i think we should yeah i mean
if i die you can craft me wait we don't have anybody to
craft okay never mind we don't have it i'm just dead okay
we're the oh i'm pretty sure we're like the only team that
has white armor right now there's no no no no we're good
we're wait why didn't we grab there's a team over here email
caches we can right now we're gonna go do I don't need an
evil cash.
I'm blue, bitches.
That's all of you, buddy.
I'm getting this cash for sure.
I'm going with Tim.
I'm watching.
I'm going with Wig just in case we get.
I charged rifle him from 450 meters.
We love that for you.
Nice job, buddy.
So proud of you.
All right.
I'm going to get a roof.
Don't worry, guys.
I am on our roof.
Fenced this up.
Dude, another team flew in there.
I'm going to fence this up, guys.
I'm doing it.
In this building?
We got to move now.
We're going to move up a little bit more.
we can't really move right now anyway because there's just
we're stuck we're stuck step bro um i want to go through
like launch but again we don't have no evac towers i don't
think we're ever gonna find evac towers no i know this is so
i don't think so guys i got one oh go tempo i've always
believed in you that's five oh my god tempo tempo tempo
where is it tempo what are you
oh my god i just got wrong dive dodge i'm safe i'm covering
i got a kill oh it was like it was in the it was on the
bridge five subs already that's my subs to tempo five subs
to me that's 10 subs dude that's insane all right when you
go command center when you get the out of this position okay
let's go to bed all right i can try i can scan again okay
let's believe it actually no way someone's gonna shoot me
right there's no I wish there was a team on south a team
just team just fenced up south that's fine that's fine we
just play near for now we need to I'm trying to find an evan
can we play in the middle up here just like realistically us
getting out of the situation without one is like yeah we
need unless like everybody suddenly collides with each other
me let me get the south team with my charge rifle all right
just in case we're good yeah just fence up nice job toki
look at me go i'm fencing go big dog yeah we're showing i'm
contributing to the team oh yeah we're alive that's also a w
i'll take not 20th all day every day i'm being so serious
shit on kid shit on kid
we're okay everything will be fine no we're power north
north middle I just realized bro my fucking we all have wait
you guys got purple and blue backpacks how did I end up with
a white backpack I had a fucking wick realistically like RV
down here wouldn't be bad I just don't know how the fuck we
get there how was I the one to end up with the shittiest
backpack out of all of you there's a team on bridge isn't
there fuck me i'm gonna go away yeah yeah the team on bridge
is the one i got a knock on or well can we get can we get
underneath this platform if we run right now i mean i don't
know when else we're gonna do it i feel like i mean it's
very risky that's for sure it is no it definitely is risky i
don't think anyone are right though and there's we just go
underneath i wish we have a rotational spot later we can't i
want to play blue bins because we're going to go against the
gibraltar team is going Well, I have all...
Wait, did you... Wait, is this guy full kill?
They're not res?
Yeah, full kill.
Did you knock the team on the left?
Well, we don't know who exactly...
I killed the team on the bridge.
Yeah, but he might... They might have res because they have
a res...
Is the res beacon activated?
Yeah, it is.
Yeah, they definitely res.
It's activated.
I was gonna say, if you kill the team on the left and we can
go there.
We could... Okay, but guys, we can scan again.
Loki could.
Well, actually, let's go back and do it.
Go do it.
I'm coming with you one side.
There's really no negative.
Exactly.
It seems three behind us.
We're good.
They're gone.
Yeah, exactly.
We can do one.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
A Gibraltar, random Gibraltar on you.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
There's one fucking dude.
Oh, he's downstairs.
Where, where, where?
He's running away.
Hit the beacon.
Okay, okay, okay.
I got really scared.
Hit the beacon and run back to me immediately because
they're above you.
Okay.
That is not very, I don't know.
I have a lot of confidence, but here we go.
Nope.
One drop down.
Are you giving me a bit.
Are you down?
I forget.
Oh, my God.
She doesn't know.
You're good.
You're...
We're so happy.
I still don't know.
I did not see the chip Check!
We need to get underneath, rather.
Wait, wait, wait.
We have no evac.
We have no kill.
You got a full kill.
Tempo is the goat.
Oh, he keeps up.
That's 10 subs each.
We need to move.
Okay, that's 10 subs each person!
Come over here.
We're gonna come over here and play this.
I have 12 needs.
Okay.
They're gonna set up your gen right here, Ducky.
We're gonna play right here.
Okay, right now?
Actually, no, don't do it.
Don't do it.
I want to see if we can get an RV.
If there's no one in RV, we should get there underneath.
Tempo.
You think you could like fuse ulti these guys up here on the
bridge that we run for RV?
Yeah, let me find their wads and gen.
It's right here.
I can destroy it.
Okay.
I'm gonna keep fencing.
I'll destroy it.
Oh, it's destroyed.
There's a fuse queue somewhere.
Oh, Jesus.
They came from in front of us.
We're fine.
Yeah, we're fine.
We just need to get in zone more which sucks.
Yeah, we are we're just at the I don't even think we're in
zone Yeah, we're not in behind my eyes.
Who the fuck is that?
I'm looking a little bit more than what he was saying this
up Yeah, so I'm so they're pushing the pushing they are Like
148 over there.
I'm kidding.
I'm kidding I'm gonna let you shot from the team in front of
us.
Yeah, you're showing them a scan again I mean, okay, I'm
good.
I'm good.
I'm good here.
Go good now.
I'm good now Jimmy's in the office spot once bubble goes
down we'll fuck him up.
I don't see him.
She'll be still over here I'm all right now swinging you're
good.
I think they want to push us in the back.
I'm checking.
No, I don't think they're going to push us in the back.
They're not.
They're just shooting like this.
I'm just kidding.
It's pretty annoying actually.
They're leaving.
They're gone.
All right.
We need to go to the RV now.
We need to jump down.
This is really bad for us actually.
Yeah, we don't have it anymore.
No, he doesn't.
I don't have it anymore.
Can you cue them?
Can you move left?
We're going to come down?
Come down?
We're going to come down.
we're so healthy we're so good we're so good we're so good
okay we are not oh no no no no no no no protect that keep
blocking that keep blocking that we're so good you're good
we're not in zone but we're so healthy you're not in zone
but you're good you're good you're good you're gonna play
without me zone okay that is all i needed to know that's
fine that's fine we're okay no go kill me what a piece of
shit you guys are good man i had a mobi on my death box by
the way we would get it get it get it get it get it i can't
get it and raise him here okay you probably could I believe
in you.
The zone doesn't hurt much.
Did you get the...
He did not get the movie.
Okay, I'll get the movie.
I'll get the movie.
I got it.
Oh, okay, okay.
Holy dysfunctional.
We got this though.
We're good.
We're fine.
You res.
Let me shoot these guys up here.
Okay, I'll res.
I'll res.
I'm looking up on the bridge.
I don't see them.
Okay.
I think we're okay, bro.
How are we not getting looked at right now?
What the fuck is going on?
Don't take this wig.
Don't cast it.
Free KP over here.
Anybody?
Like, what?
We're good.
I'm just kidding.
All right.
Don't worry.
My fences will protect us.
All right.
We need to get in that corner.
They're fighting on bridge.
You guys should go to RV right now.
RV.
Let's go.
Go.
They're watching now.
They're in someone's inside.
There's someone inside RV.
What do you mean?
He's in the RV.
RV is flesh.
He's dead, dead, dead, dead, dead, dead!
No, we lost him, but that's okay.
Okay, wait, we have a strat here, though.
We have a strat.
We're gonna get in this corner over here, Salon, okay?
You still have your Moby if you loot your body.
I didn't loot it.
I couldn't loot anything, him.
Wait, does that guy have a body?
No, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
Okay, wait, Salon, we have a play.
I'm not even kidding.
We have a play.
Okay.
We're gonna get into this corner.
Come here.
Come, come, come, come, come.
Come to me.
I don't know if I want to see it.
Are you sure?
That's a good placement.
Come here.
Trust us.
Okay.
I might die now because I hesitated.
Oh my God.
Don't be a little bitch.
I hesitated.
There's no way.
It didn't matter.
There was a full team running back.
But no, they were on the other side of the rock.
If we get there, we're vibing.
Oh my God.
Not a single EVAC.
we supposed to do it's okay we got three kills because tempo
we got three kills we got four points four points guys i'll
take four points actually not bad like actually four points
is like the 10th place area we're good yeah and also no stan
no evac what are you doing that's pretty good of course i
got a pure howl tempo go over there and and hold his pc
hostage right now and summon his monitor immediately.
Yeah, yeah.
Run over there, take his monitor, show it on stream, and
give Val a message.
Yeah.
Snipe down killed you and Hal.
I got a tag team, bro.
I got Eiffel towered by the fucking XTSM.
Guys, we got four kills and we didn't die 20th.
That's all that matters.
I'm not gonna lie.
That was like pretty good.
Yeah, that was pretty good with the situation we were in.
I mean, that was all, yeah, that situation was like pretty
terrible.
Yeah, that was pretty terrible.
fucking terrible I feel like that's what we say every time
we're like no that was like really bad for us but we did
kind of good that's what that's what we say that's like our
motto okay temple how many kills it yet you got he got two
kills so that's 10 subs each fuck me yeah pay up oh shit i'm
torched oh my god my moderator still alive w you're
moderators yeah he is aligar he's the has a higher placement
than us, he should give us some of his prize winnings.
Alright, I'm back.
Yeah, that's how that works if I don't pay him to be my mod.
Yeah.
But I still take a percentage of his wins.
Our money now.
No, 100%.
That's exactly how Twitch works.
Yeah.
Low key.
A little bit.
We're still alive.
Oh, sweet still alive, of course.
And the prize is cock clan just going crazy.
Oh.
This is so...
funny only i think if we had zone in any way we definitely
would have lived longer oh no if we had shown we could have
like went to lava siphon took balloon you know what i mean
yeah we would have been so healthy yeah i wanted to get that
rv pretty bad we got that rv early where we could oh we sort
of lost somebody erinoco he came out of the rv solo bro i
didn't realize anyone was there and i'm just needing the
bridge and then a noco just comes out and then i have to
mark him the guy was so confident that i thought it was a
full team so i went to the side no i mean we did we honestly
did a good job we got in there we killed a good die
realistically i should have got to kill him then he brought
it up top too almost one clean way for like a thousand
levels i was crazy probably the only time i'll have a good
shot today that's okay this is our peak guys this is the
best gameplay you're gonna see out of all of us this is the
this is the start of the damage we get plus one kill after
every game which means yeah there's no way we can be last
because kills game six there's no way we can be last because
we're we already started out strong with with with kills
yeah no i was hoping i was hoping someone would miss pick a
legend and they'd get minus five and then they'd get like
bottom five and then they just their scoreboard is just
negative anyone miss pick a legend there must have been one
person they said they were gonna restart if they if uh bro
what the fuck babies 20 teams up 59 players alive how Okay,
nice.
We didn't restart.
I mean, not nice.
Not nice.
I'm nice.
I'm not nice.
They're already two people over advantage.
It's called survival the fittest.
We were able to.
We were able to connect.
We were able to evolve to what we are.
We're about to, we didn't survive the fittest.
I did not do this tournament so Imperial Howe can make more
money.
He's buying me dinner.
You should have not invited him.
That would go so good.
so well thank god we'll take second place holy all right
wait wait okay all right it was like everybody's invited
except for how i know that was like having those comps are
kind of fun i kind of like seeing the legend obviously that
was good time yeah yeah guys i can't believe i got hit with
a sentinel and then a repeater when i died like that that
was so fast yeah i don't know i feel like even Even if I
trusted you, Wig, we would have still died.
They won't.
Oh, no, no.
I don't know.
Even if I trusted you and we ran at the same time, we
still...
We would have still died.
Because I got...
Yeah, probably.
Yeah.
No, no.
They were already heading towards you.
They were...
Yeah.
Hal scanning a duo is just...
It's GG's.
I think he just literally started foaming out of his mouth.
He was so ready for it.
He scans us.
He just swipes us for sure.
Damn you, tempo.
Yeah.
My god, it's fucking awesome.
Who was charged rifling?
It was me.
I'm gonna take credit.
Oh no, peep got dc'd?
Fuck, that sucks.
We didn't restart.
Oh Did I ask for a non-mode or does not matter?
No, no, wait, wait, wait.
No, no, don't ask for it.
No, wait, wait, wait.
Don't ask for it.
It'll be more fun.
I already did it.
I need to go to their channels and clip them raging because
I need to.
Oh my God.
I need to know who I'm killing.
His little YouTube compilation.
He's going to make the pros rage at me.
Apex Legends compilation.
You won't believe which pro got angry at me.
Yeah, I'm going to help you with the clickbait type of
thing.
is you're so you're so good at that wait what what do we
what do we uh do we get our subs bang rate octane belt seer
cat new castle conduit oh they announced it okay oh i could
do catalyst i'll do the controller oh wait we'll announce
the legends yeah yeah yeah
and you cast a conduit because dokey's going cat yeah we
have valk we have that i mean i mean wait wait that means
you you can take octane and i'll take that do we trust
temple on valk this is where what is that right because wait
who played valk when we played last time um that was me you
played watson and doki played uh well yeah dokey played uh
what did i bang bang bang oh yeah but bangs nerfed right
yeah she i mean yeah she's not bad isn't like the bang smoke
something something the one you're so good you said two
words and then the words that mattered was not there well
something changed i just don't know what the something was
okay a lot of things changed definitely you gotta be more
specific here all right my brain is telling me i should play
heart saying octane you should listen to your brain the
times you've listened to your heart oh you're still right my
heart told me to pick you guys and my brain was like what
the fuck are you doing so maybe i should have listened to my
brain in that situation so in this situation your heart
picked us your heart didn't pick you guys which is the right
choice so i'm going octane next game who you guys play okay
then i'll take valk okay wait next okay yeah so we can and
then i'll do catalyst yeah you can do cat bang whoever
you're comfortable with all right i'll do cat we need zone
readers yeah this could be a good zone this could be a good
when when i am the rational one in this team that's when you
know things are bad oh wait my valk has a oh no wait no it's
the challenges my valk is locked wait has wake tempo did
wake give you 10 subs yet no i'll give it i'll do it after
oh okay oh we we're gonna we're gonna stack every time you
get a kill it's a plus five just remember that okay pemo
he's gonna literally find your lifestyle what map are you on
we're on we're on with storm point storm point storm point
okay storm point is blue right storm point we're going
command so can we can we give alcold the other right yeah oh
yeah oh we're good we're so we're so healthy we're so
healthy i was i was trying to pick my belt oh sorry my skin
oh yeah yeah i need to pick Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm trying to make it blend into the wall.
Okay, you're right, you're right.
I'm not gonna, I need to rearrange my, rearrange my badges.
Oh, wait, my Valk badge.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I was, I was gonna play, I already forgot what I was
playing.
Catalyst, Catalyst, yes.
Okay, banner.
Don't worry.
I'm gonna make sure everybody knows what rank I'm in.
Oh, I almost, I almost queued up for rank.
I just want you to know, I have zero.
kills on catalysts i think i also have zero wait a minute no
wait wait wait i was too busy with jeff burton what did you
just say i have zero kills on catalysts zero cat kills and
you chose cat over bank yeah yeah so what is what is cat's
passive Lock doors.
Oh wait, no, that's a door.
That's it.
She can throw out the spikes.
She can lock the doors.
Lock the doors is crazy.
Yeah, sure.
Yeah.
I mean, technically it's locking doors.
And then she can, she can put up a wall.
And, and she looks, she looks like, She looks slay while
doing it.
She does look slay, to be honest.
I'm so happy Trick 2G is playing, bro.
I used to watch Trick 2G like every day in league.
When I was an avid league player and I wanted to fucking cry
every day, that's who I watched.
Oh yeah, that's what I was gonna say.
You played league.
I'm just gonna say like, are you okay?
Are you?
Are you okay?
peak you're not out of the box silver to peak yeah yeah
you're like that oh wait i don't know if i can say it you're
like that one guy that was like silver or something and he
played league his whole career and then and then he tried to
own an esport org you know that guy sam bankman freed yeah
the crypto dude he just got 25 years in jail yeah i saw that
i was assured we could talk Oh, true.
That's true.
What was the point called?
FTX?
Yeah.
Hey, Tempo.
What was it called again?
Tempo, you remember that coin that had a deal with TSM?
Yeah.
I promised you guys like $200 million.
That guy.
The one that's been like apparently like bronze or whatever
after 10 years of league.
So then he decided to own an esport org.
That guy.
It's a good thing we could talk about it.
Yeah, he should be able to openly talk about this, you know?
It's okay, Tempo.
That whole shit is actually great.
Yeah, I'm surprised.
Like, I'm surprised he got, he almost got away with it.
Until he got 25 years in prison.
I don't even know that's enough, though.
I was like the biggest heist ever.
Yeah.
He almost got away with it, too.
And we went for this meddling kids.
I'm trying to pull that.
yeah 35 million and 35 years yeah he made an entire eastport
court to change your name yeah and he also paid off for um
there's another there's like a basketball team i think oh
yeah yeah we have crypto yeah yeah crazy that's actually he
did everything with that money he did everything with that
money to actually do what he was supposed to do what's on
back guys yeah oh you missed that whole thing you missed our
we're in like ninth place all right we're not we're top 10
we're like tie for nine there's like five people with four
points nice we got this all right wait what what i was i was
i was they started showing the standings and i was so
invested to see where we were you're so completely zoned out
hopefully that's good that's good we were talking really
great about tsm okay yeah that's good that's good that's
good yeah don't worry we're hyping tsm up yeah so you won't
get fired never never we will never do that about that hello
something you didn't tell us or what whoa temple temple what
happened big can i sleep on your couch i told you bro land
my couch is yours i got you i got you on warm milk at night
if you need like whatever you want bro i'm down bro was this
morning morning juice box and everything i got you dude
you'll actually to be just treated like a king in my
apartment holy when that's on slipped over he didn't have a
blanket and i had he had to use one of the pillows as a
blanket oh i'm taking all your juvie wait are they kicking
you out of the house no this is for right or i was about to
say this is where twitch rivals oh are you going to land
don't hear no no wait is that in la yeah yeah is it la
what's what date is it uh what is it 2nd may 2nd yeah may
2nd okay that's like a far i can still i still have time to
think about it when am i gonna be on your b stream when can
i roll up yeah literally roll up on an ipad yeah yeah roll
up on an ipad obviously come through you gotta actually buy
one of those no tempo's gonna buy it for me huh huh the most
broke one out of the No, no, no, no, I'm not a million.
I'm not at million.
I am like, I'm a poor, I'm very, I'm very tiny.
I'm a pretty tiny streamer.
I just started a month ago, guys.
I just started a month ago.
Oh, so true.
You're brand new to this.
Yeah, I'm brand new.
I charge up those sweep in the side of the head for 140.
Good for you.
You didn't get the kill, though, man.
What's wrong with you?
I don't know.
I have no idea.
He typed it, not me.
Also, I thought Tempo, I thought you had it.
the setup already because you were gonna do it on last land.
What happened?
I didn't buy it.
I didn't buy the roller coaster thing.
Of course you didn't buy it.
You didn't even buy it?
You literally told me like, oh, TSA won't let me do it.
I have the iPad?
Yes, he has the iPad.
I have the tablet.
I need the rolly thingy with the wheels.
Ask EA to buy it.
We'll make it off as a business expense.
That is so smart.
That's a good idea.
We all have good connections with EA staff.
Yeah, let me go talk to Chen.
Yeah, we can literally convince them because it's an la
instead of like london so it's we don't have to get a plane
we can return it to the respawn h2 exactly and then they can
reuse it every time i want to i want to butt in oh you can
you can play test with the no we cannot roll rolling ipads
gonna go straight into me terrorize terrorize all the staff
that are working no i'm just all right wait wait we need to
pay attention here we might be conned guys we might be kind
maybe i don't know i'm just double checking We have no
beacon.
Again?
What the fuck is the point of playing?
No, we have no beacon.
Character, of course we have no beacon.
Wait, isn't...
We didn't pick a control character.
We're just rolling.
Wait.
No, I mean a map scan.
Oh, oh, wait.
Wait, there's someone like...
No, I'm Catalyst.
Isn't Catalyst can scan maps?
Yeah, you are, yeah, you are, yeah.
Yeah, what the fuck?
You're literally the fucking casting!
I'm watching, I'm watching, I'm watching, I'm watching, I'm
watching, I'm watching, I'm watching.
You watch so many apex streams that you still don't know
who's the controller.
we're on tat bro i forgot oh my gosh we have a little bit we
have the don't you forget it i'm sorry where are you guys
i'm so confused i have i have a jump tower guys we're so set
on me on me on me team here team i told you i knew it we're
getting we're actually getting contested no way i'm getting
contested in my own tournament yeah what the they saw that I
see one up all the way up there.
We wanna get height, that's the problem here.
Wait, can we just not?
Can we not take this at now?
No, I don't think we can, they're already covering it.
Bro, they're taking it right now.
My audio's not.
Fucking shit.
Your audio?
There we go, we're good.
My audio's back on.
You had no audio?
Bro.
All right, where's someone we can rotate you that has it?
We can go lower.
I forgot I lowered my, oh, you didn't ping the charge I
pulled.
I'm sorry, I was a little bit confluster.
Yeah, he was at 6x.
On the other side of the map.
oh six x they're leaving oh i'm rich all right i don't have
a wig all right they're leaving we're gonna go over to where
they were and we're gonna go on the zip line again okay
because we want to take height we definitely do i'm right
behind you if anything happens that's fine thank you if
anything happens we can not craft you because we don't have
that wait they're still here they're still here they shot do
they shoot you tempo all right no i shot you they're pushing
let's just leave yeah oh okay going through this door though
yeah just leave i'm gonna lock the door i just don't know if
the zone's going this way and we're gonna get ran out
because the zone actually looks like it could be let's take
this let's take this house to our right side right now all
right let's get nowhere to the zone's going i'd rather just
be safe and just go to wall later okay guys we can grab the
um yeah the the hash thing after yeah i'm done okay guys i
haven't like catalyst in a while so how many spikes can i do
the bottom one yeah just go down just go down okay i'm
heading down we're so healthy why sir oh i just went
straight up oh don't die there please yeah we're gonna play
for here right now and see what goes on we get the evo cash
here as well suck it just pay attention there's definitely
someone that could be posting up coming to us yeah yeah just
set up right now fuck it we're getting we're getting hoed
right now i'm pretty hard i can't lie i'm locking this door
whoo these people are not like us apparently it sucks this
guy is for this i am like not confident right now actually
we're not like a bad spot regardless of where the zone goes
so we should be fine oh what about our loot oh yeah we can
go over to uh wall after this and just probably get i don't
i don't see someone was shooting us from here but I have
like no long range so I'm just gonna oh there's a long bow
here for anybody I would take my ammo I'm gonna run this
then for long range I dropped a vault if anyone wants a
vault I have a vault already this team's not staying on the
height of that building with just making me think it's not
going here oh wait actually someone just landed on top yep
yeah it's making me think it is going over there which is
pretty good I think we just stay in this house in for a now
yeah yeah let's just not waste any loot because we we're
very have a lot Yeah, we're pretty poor right now.
Anyone kind of like to donate loot to us?
Please, we need it.
Please.
Here, evacking.
If anybody's stream sniping.
Wait, Doki, do you have queues at all?
Yeah.
You try to put one on the window just for the peek?
Oh, yeah, sure.
I think you can.
Put which one here?
Wait, there's any other windows.
I'm on hideous shooting someone that's going this way.
All right.
That's not great.
Is that all right?
yeah for visual clutter it doesn't matter as long as it
makes it just drop back down to they're not on height
anymore i'm stressed i'm stressed we're you stressed araba
we have good position we should loot but like as long as
they don't come in and kill us probably a cell yeah i only
problem is we're just triple wipe someone shoots that thing
like okay then just don't get shot we're in the cure packs
can't we scan them i tried i didn't look quick enough i'm an
idiot oh wait they're fighting in cascades that's fine i can
get a blue off of this yeah yeah try to farm some ship yeah
you farm for us we're just gonna look be here yeah you get
your shield up buddy yeah yeah you're our sniper does this
team still up i have four cells okay i have some here here
oh my god do you guys remember the strat that we were
supposed to do last time we're like uh you know remember the
one where uh we let tempo drop wherever the he wants and
then i do remember We never did that strat.
We did that so bad.
We were in the last game today.
You gotta crack?
We did that for, oh shit, he's in that room.
Of course.
Of course he is.
On roof, we're dead here.
We're so dead.
What are we?
What are we gonna do?
We need to go wall, so I need to go wall.
I'm leaving, I'm leaving.
I'm leaving.
I'll make it so they can't find me.
You're dead.
We should've made tempo.
here too we should have made you on top of the building
tempo yes yeah he was by the way you okay they have no idea
i'm here i'm dead for you yes it doesn't matter drop got me
they're sending us they're pushing us they're definitely you
run you run let me die don't You shouldn't have been a hero.
Oh, my.
We got 20th tempo.
Tempo.
We got tempo, man.
We're not last.
We're dead center zone.
Tempo.
Wait, we're not center zone.
Oh, Rob's saying that in that zone we were.
Oh, yeah.
Tempo.
It's the 20th place, bro.
And no beacon for all.
Again, does this game hate us?
Okay, what if like in our third game we let tempo that way?
We let tempo go wherever the fuck you want.
No, because no, no, because this next game is Olympus and we
have a good PY.
We have phase drivers.
That's what you said about last game.
We have infinite balls.
Infinite, infinite, infinite balls.
Why don't we get contested?
Well, no.
No, we might get contested.
Yeah, we don't get.
Yeah.
People see our names like, oh, Timmy is based.
Oh, fuck.
We do not want to fight that guy.
I thought you said we had to do that.
Hold out of my own tournament, dude.
What is this shit?
What's going on?
We go find some.
Is there anyone that's free, Chappo?
I can't believe it.
I was so talented.
Matt.
Super unfortunate.
Wait, this is why you don't follow your heart i mean why am
i getting contested at command center you followed your
heart and then we got 20th place command center no beacon
and we're contested my strategy is just fucked out the
window there because the whole point is i wanted to get
beacon then valkyles come up there so we don't have to shoot
for the rest of the game you just know exactly where to go
because tempo's sitting on top of roofs
with his back no no comment with his back very bottom i was
shooting someone yeah but you shot in the back my i was
shooting cascades and then i don't know where those guys
came from and they were in the house next to us all right
we'll see what we got i found a map okay wait did we get
zero points that get a zero point no yes we were 20 wait i
don't know i wasn't sure if we got to kill i don't know
about work some magic with that charge rifle you know what i
mean i wasn't sure
No one's good.
Temba, what's free?
What's free for the next map?
We're moving on.
Memory like a goldfish.
What's free?
Interesting.
Oh, here it is.
Next.
What's free?
Do we have anything?
Do we...
Is there...
We should...
If we...
Oh my god.
I have an idea.
If there's no...
If there's no spot free, we see who's the 20th place team.
And we land on them That's us No, I meant overall Overall
It's not fucked up That's not fucked up No, no, no We're
Dude, we're weak We're weak on the weaker That's fair as
fuck Yeah, yeah It's strategy It's strategy And people can
do that In pro league And fuck over other teams We can too
Yeah, that's Cause there's no Just prayed on the weaker
Yeah, there's no rules Against doing that Against sabotaging
other teams Yep Yeah, okay, so we just need to find out
whose overall 20th place and then take their then take their
POI I Don't know if we can even be 20th place I don't
there's no way I think we are the 20 in terms of gum skill.
No, no, I think we are the 20th There's one open POI
turbine.
Oh, that's good.
Oh, okay.
Let's do it.
Let's get turbine.
Yeah, yeah, yeah Say turbine in chat, please or You're gonna
change your thingy.
Guys, or we can get three points and land on the 20th team
overall.
But here's the thing, if we lose the 20th place team, what
the fuck are we gonna do?
Then we're the 20th place team.
Then we're fucking bad.
And then we become the 20th place team.
Oh my gosh.
Are you, do you not believe in this way?
I believe in, I...
Okay, okay, do you not believe in me.
Let's not add tempo into the equation.
No, no, I believe in you, but like...
Yeah, yeah, okay.
You want to play at three player, you know?
i mean yeah yeah i'm pretty good for a platform player you
know you think about it yeah yeah for a platform player is
that pretty good if we get like if we get like tempo not to
die we're good to go you know what i'm saying that's true
hey we're good i'm back tempo got us two points last game
yeah yeah that's the thing we need him to be alive to farm
points for us all right yeah we just need a i just i'm
confused it's you know why you know why that happened
because i was on and i was like oh i can fly and then i flew
to the roof honestly this is what wait this is if i was if i
was any other legend i would not have been able to make it
up on the roof and i'd be like way this is why you never
listen to your heart i was trying to be a good teammate he
was so excited play valg i don't know what you say to be a
good teammate you seem that you're like i'm gonna play valg
no because he wanted you to play octane tempo was the one
that was trying to be a good teammate realistically
realistically we want to be honest here tempo should be
playing the controller characters okay okay yeah you know
i'll take i'll take all the controllers unless there's a
fuse okay wait tell them not to put fuse in yeah i might
message them to say not to put fuse in yeah tell them to
remove all fuses from now on show them my chat says you
realize that dokey still has zero kills on cat yeah you
still have zero kills on cat yeah dude keeping that
tradition less than 100 dead we're so towards why is there
so many teams a alive still.
Watch because we died pretty early.
Yeah, that's because...
We didn't even get the Valculte that game.
We didn't even get any old.
Guys, 20th place by own tournament is crazy.
Yeah.
You have to get at least 19th next game.
We have to.
Please, please.
We're not improving.
No one's contesting next game.
Guys.
Okay.
That's good.
Okay, that's good.
That's already like one thing we don't have to worry about.
That's true.
No, that also means no one's going to die to me.
We got to not die right.
We should tell everybody what our skins are so they won't
run at us.
And then we'll give them someone else's skin so that they
chase after.
That is so true.
What is this team skins?
Yellow Bang.
I'm now a yellow bang.
We'll all play yellow skins.
I'm down.
It's like bright yellow or bright pink.
No, no.
We're giving people...
Wait, wait.
What map are we playing on?
Olympus next.
We're giving people other people's skins.
place my mom in the chat said i'm back what's happening mom
we just got 20th place no you could have lied she wouldn't
know we got first last game somewhere i think we're i think
um we got we were doing so well that ea staff told us to sit
this one out so other people can watch parting from inside
the game now yeah i want to say right now that this is
better than international scrims quality we have 14 teams
alive after 12 seconds of the first game people don't get
money Of course, this is better.
Your show, right?
Your show, right.
Money changed.
Even if they did.
Not for us, though.
Not for us.
We're not changing anything for us.
We're literally content.
No, Temple, you should start giving vouchers for your scrims
so people take it more seriously.
Like, a $5 coupon for something.
A $5 coupon?
We'll give you a sub.
We'll give you five subs if you survive.
Pass around.
so true that's so true that's how that's how we should do
the payout yeah instead of instead of overall placement if
you survive every team that's around like pass round three
for every for every round you survive your team earns extra
money it like earns like five subs yeah per person that
would be financed by wig yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah like the
bank account for everybody yeah got you okay but wait it'll
give you better quality scrims which means better like more
viewers in general which means more income in general so
you're in the end you're gonna gain money in the end yeah
yeah because viewers would want to watch better scrims
because the scrims will be longer too yeah yeah so more and
then you can run as many ads as you want sorry guys i'm
gonna run ads now that's a funny joke he has a fascination
with me spending money she's like listen like tempo gets
these kills you just drop like 600 bucks each like it's not
that big it's motivation money motivates people it's true
look at look at right now you've never had look at the
quality of this of money this is the most motivated i've
seen sniped down a very long time you whoa him not being
relegated him being relegated probably didn't help this is
good he's playing like he's 10 years younger right now oh
yeah and his eyes and he just died and he gets beeped across
the map you had to stay regulated yeah No fucking way, dude.
You just actually VTuber cursed him so hard.
You're the one that mentioned his name first.
What do you mean?
I was talking about getting money motivation.
Yeah, but you're here.
You're here.
I'm here.
I give the extra curse.
Agreed.
There's got to be something along with VTubers and curses.
They don't make sense.
No, I think casters give a better curse than VTubers.
I will agree that I definitely give a harder curse.
Yeah.
I'll agree with that one.
This is a hard zone.
I'm going to be honest guys, I'm kind of happy we died.
What do you mean?
No.
You're happy that we died 20th?
Yeah, a little bit because I don't think we embarrass
ourselves in this zone.
We would have been on that house on the left side.
Uh-huh.
We could have vouched over there and got the house.
That would have been us.
I just, I think the tempo is just a boss for that.
Just sitting on top of a roof like that is crazy.
Yeah, with white armor, that was actually crazy.
no you're a piece of that like all confidence white armor
did you not take you on white armor i don't know you leveled
up into that right here i mean i don't think it would help
he was dead regardless if it was white or blue if i had blue
i would have been alive you were literally dead he's still
charged rightfully tempo your reaction time on that was
crazy how do you know you didn't see anything you were just
dead you're still in the same spot i looked up And you were
still standing still when you were getting shot.
What do you mean?
I don't know what you're talking about.
I'm talking about you, Tempo.
Jersey's off.
Are you taking off your fucking shirt right now on stream?
I'm ready.
No.
The day I stop playing is the day Tempo plays in a
tournament with me shirtless.
He's gonna... Bro, he's shirtless right now!
Look at this.
Is that toss?
Can you play with your titties out?
No, it'd be like, you know, like those, like, like, nipple
stickers that they, to, like, on Twitch, people who do it on
Twitch for body paint.
Pasty's, the pasties, the pasties.
How do you know the name of that?
I mean, I'd be knowing things.
How do you know their name?
I used to watch makeup tutorials when I was younger, all the
time.
Really?
Wait, really?
Yeah, I was, like, interested in makeup for a while.
Oh, shit.
No, I do not wear pasties.
Why not?
I'm fucking naked.
Bro, but you had a fascination.
No, I was just interested with makeup.
I was like, oh, these people are good at it.
You know what I'm saying?
How many?
Okay, if you put that as a goal.
What?
To wear pasties on street?
There is not a single goal that would get me shirtless with
nipple tassels on my fucking skin.
tassels but like just cover it as if you have no nipples i
would actually rather have tassels than any of us wait wait
why would you not want to be nippleless right i don't want
to see what i look like like that oh my god someone said you
could make them spin that's what i'm saying that's why all
right we're back what do you mean we're back we've been dead
the whole time we've been here the I went to go grab.
Wait, are you actually shirtless right now?
No.
Bro, no balls.
No balls is crazy.
No.
Hey, wait.
Oh, no, no, he's dead.
Oh, God, who's winning?
Just tell me who is winning.
Well, not Drops team.
We just saw him got bowed down, man.
Got rocked.
You gotta make sure I'm anonymous next game.
I should have all the pros one.
This is more fun.
I mean, it is.
I agree.
Jim Brunson won.
Of course he did it.
Of course.
Wait, so you wouldn't.
Wait, you wouldn't wear it.
I'm going to turn my audio back on.
Why wouldn't you wear Paises?
Why are you afraid of being like nipple-less?
I don't understand, Whig.
I just don't want to see what I look like without- I don't
know.
I'm just- I mean, I'm down, but I hope I'm trying to do it
on stream.
You know what I mean?
Like, I'm not trying to be like, no nipples on stream.
I'm not even trying to show my nipples on stream.
But it's not against TOS.
No, I like fully understand it's not against TOS.
It's just like, you know, I'm not trying to just show my
nip.
But you won't be showing it because it won't be seen.
Dropped, bro.
Why did you do that to poor tempo?
Man was scoped in 499, nine times charge rifling.
Bro, people, your chat wants it.
They want that content.
Of course my chat wants it.
They see me as a piece of me.
I bend over to turn my Christmas tree on, and it's just
non-stop fucking comments.
Why do you have a Christmas tree on so you can make an
excuse to bend over?
No, I should get a whiteboard, though.
Oh, you should.
Every time, like, you use it to put the scores down for
scrims.
So every time you're like, oh, this team won, you can bend.
You can turn it around.
Oh, look at these winners.
Look at all these scrim winners.
That's content right there.
content.
I'm asking Drop how bad your reaction time was.
Yo, the game doesn't count.
Okay.
Cause anonymous zone was supposed to happen, but it didn't.
So the whole game is, is a, is a, oh my God.
Yes.
The wipe thingy.
Wake.
Tell them right now.
It probably can do that.
We can do a tournament.
Since it's your tournament, this game doesn't count because
anonymous was not on.
Yeah.
Wait, tell them that right now.
All righty.
Where am I?
What am I telling them?
What am I doing?
Tell them.
that because anonymous mode was not on when you told him it
doesn't count it doesn't count this game is wiped off for
sure i think they're totally gonna listen to me after
they've paid for everyone to be there for a certain amount
of hours no i'll just know i mean obviously i think donkeys
right i'll just put another i'll put like 20 000 my own
money into this exactly yeah exactly you can make it back by
having a whiteboard you're a genius you're a genius yeah you
can add and you break even exactly one add 20 000 yeah that
works that works that works you're like maybe two legends
new legends maybe two ads ash boy oh yeah crypto vantage
caustic lifeline all right obviously tempos caustic yes all
right we're on oh Olympus I need a I need a white all right
um I mean to be fair the other ones are just wherever you're
comfortable with Oh, bro, I'm down with anything, honestly.
I mean, we can do lifeline just to craft people if Tempo
dies.
Or wait, no, actually, and Wig dies because you're the...
You're going to be taking most of the hits.
I should probably play Path for rotational purposes.
I'll play Path for our rotations, zip lines and stuff.
I'll play Lifeline for the Crafter.
Okay, you cool with that?
Yeah, I'm cool with that.
all right all right let me change my we're we're locked in
guys we're locked in we're gonna get a beacon and turbine
because this map which my life got have a beacon all right
okay lifeline i'm both gonna need therapy after today no i
need therapy after 10 above today that's my dog all right i
went to therapy once i did too you only once guys yeah yeah
it's way more hey should go more than one because you went
once of course it didn't work out yeah it was never gonna
work out you don't know that you need to find the right
therapist and the issues will nah are impossible whoa what
issues are impossible all right okay you know what tempo
trauma dump on us right now we're like you are a sociopath
and i was like what wait really no oh okay i was
holy and you were a teacher around children you think you
think sweet comes a turbine just to go wait that that's why
i was that's why i wait let's see i'm making sure thing turn
me into one that's the way no yeah fucking what children
can't turn you into a sociopath your your your what is the
340 i'm so if we get contested that if we get contested that
turbine we're so shocked guys i can't wait so we'll late
drop turbine because if someone tries to contest this
turbine, it means another POI is open.
There's one team, right?
Yeah.
There's one team per POI right now.
Okay.
We'll just late drop and if someone contests us it would
destroy a 2009 their PC.
I mean, no one's doing turbine, I don't think.
There's no one doing turbine.
Yeah.
So we're fine.
Oh, we're fine.
Okay, I'm gonna be like, we are landing.
If someone swears.
Yeah.
Guys, we fight them.
Guys, we, wait.
guys we should make a team paranoid who's like the 20th team
overall somewhere else are we 20th yeah yeah yeah no no no i
want to make a team i want to make a team paranoid by saying
we're landing on their poi so you think they're getting
contested who's laughing no wait no that's five egg because
because then someone will try and kill us off drop and then
yeah that's why there's three teams exactly then they'll
really be contesting the other team yeah that's why i'm
big-braining this right now who's the 20th team and what's
your po i'm looking at the leaderboard i mean i'm waiting
for the leaderboard to get updated the way website guys i'm
gonna be honest can i can i say a statement that we might
not like here okay i'm uh like what is ours i i did not
believe in us for challenger circuit at all
wait a minute i believe in us less wait a minute i'm glad so
i'm glad you said it because i don't we're gonna be going
against we're we're we're against makeshift teams right now
okay when we go to challengers we're gonna be against teams
that have been playing together for a little bit yeah and
i've been screaming and everything people people who are
playing on a touchpad that have been playing together are
still not going to be able to hit anything so you think
these people are playing on ipads and challenges they're on
the switch they join the challenge oh no no not that they're
actually not that they're actually playing on a switch but
they might as well be playing on a switch they can't hit
anything oh i see that's for sure no no no they're uploading
the two score they're uploading the scores right now where i
think we're last i think there's no way that's so sad we
have four we have four points we have to be no there's no
don't say It was like, there was like five teams, there's
like, there's like 10 teams below us.
You find the scores over here.
I already looked.
Do you select final results?
Don't say that.
There has to be a team.
A team more?
So they uploaded.
That's not, that's not, that's not.
They haven't uploaded a score.
Okay, let's just look at the current last place team and
this, say their POI.
Oh, final results.
I see.
All right.
It's not, it's not uploaded.
How the fuck Timmy is last place right now?
ninth timmy's in last no we're in ninth no no not yet not
yet that's the round one that's round one fuck there's three
people first three teams with zero points it's timmy we the
people and kian okay yeah yeah yeah all right wait where is
where is where are they landing i'm gonna look at where the
landing right timmy was landing phase okay kian's team's
really good i'm not trying to land on that okay uh who's
kian's team where is terminal is terminal is terminal on
Wait, what's our third map?
My middle of a third map, Donky?
I know, this is the job spot.
I think trombus.
We're playing Olympus.
I was going to say it's terminal in Olympus.
Okay, we're landing in an Olympus.
I'm going to say we're landing a terminal.
No, but what if they land on turbine now thinking we're
going terminal?
No, they won't.
No, we don't go terminal.
I said we're landing terminal.
There's no way.
If they do that, we're fucked.
There's no way they're the last place.
Oh wait.
They have kind never mind.
I'm scared The last place we just got back.
I have no idea how they're last They're good.
Wait, they're not wait.
It's not updated yet though.
That's why and they have a control player, too No, no, no,
they're saying they're saying terminal.
They're saying we will fight you and you die to us in
terminal law
just out making enemies i'm just i'm like i'm baiting i'm
baiting him i'm baiting him right now okay so hopefully
sweet goes over there and kills kind and then and then we'll
get 19.
i'm landing on your wig great peep just bc'd through the
game no no no it's started started bro what you're such a
snitch way wig the vibes were high until tempo got his head
taken off I rewatched rewatched what he rewatched the
fucking clip he re-hacked the 20 seconds after Bro, what the
fuck, Demo?
I didn't react twice.
It wasn't 20 seconds, okay?
It was like, it was like 10.
How does that make it better?
I don't know if that makes it better.
10 seconds, okay?
That is very fast.
10 seconds reaction time?
Remember, did you have a six times or a four to eight?
Yeah, six.
I was trying to make sure.
Makes a lot of sense.
Yeah, six.
It's not my fault.
It's a six X.
it's not my fault yeah yeah it's a scope guys it's not his
fault guys worry we'll make it back all right let's get to
let's get to 15 points so we need what 11 11 11 is so doable
guys we 11 points we need we need a god we need six kills in
fourth place oh yeah yeah yeah we need a beacon and we did
an e-back tower and we're so i had an e-back tower too yeah
i told you guys i know but we got stuck on command bro how
did they get into command if we went in the middle because
they went front side i think they thought that no one was
there so there's one in the front and then because we went
through the butthole yeah they didn't they might not come
back next they might not they might not come back next one
we'll see oh right we're playing there again wait we have
Wait, wait.
That means that I can see where in Stormpoint is.
How the hell said that sucks, Storm?
I just got jury duty.
Have fun, man.
Are you supposed to go to jury duty like yearly?
No.
You can pretend.
You can.
You get R&G for jury duty.
Yeah, you get R&G for jury duty, and then you can tell them
that you're not competent enough to be a... Yeah, just say
you're stupid.
I would do that 100%.
Just be like, I'm like, get on like a really crazy intense
big case that would be scary that's why you don't take the
case that's why you take it that's why you take it and then
you know okay here's like the here's how to get out of like
jerry okay as a not an american but like this is how you
can't wait wait wait wait character pathfinder don't you're
playing lifeline and okay what do you find I'll stick.
Wait, can the leader of the prison?
I'll be in Canada.
Yes, I saw him.
Okay.
As I was saying, like to get out jury duty, if it's like
something that's like a really high prolific case, you can
be like, I sympathize with the murderer.
And then you're already have like a bias towards the.
And then they're like, oh, I guess we can't have you.
Yeah.
Because you have to be in jury duty, you have to have no
biases at all.
So you can you can just be like, I don't know.
I think he could be he.
I think he was a nice guy.
I think he's a nice guy.
So you get out of jury duty.
Why don't you just say that to the victims instead?
Like I sympathize with them.
Well, you don't say it to the victims.
You say it to the judge because they're picking the people
who are doing jury duty.
You know, you're right, man.
Yeah, so they won't know you said that.
You know, the victims won't know.
Only the judge will know.
And then they'll be like, we can't put you in jury duty
because you already have a bias towards the murderer.
I don't think you have to worry at all, Doki.
I don't think you're ever getting picked based off these
estate you say they're watching they're watching you know
take this seriously show us algae league it's a joke it's
not a joke get her it's a joke it was a joke guys for legal
reasons this is a joke no for legal reasons she's being
serious better do not take my mile minus tempo on caustic
Wait, we don't beacon again.
I'm gonna fucking cry.
I might cry.
Just jump right now before someone just jump, tempo, jump,
please.
Before somebody tries to- Watch my jumping.
Before somebody takes turbine from us.
Yeah, please.
We need something in this world.
Yeah.
How do we not have a fucking beacon again?
This game actually wants me to go out.
I don't want to be part of five, guys.
What did you just say?
I don't want to be bottom five, guys.
No, that's give a sale.
No, that ship is gone.
What are you talking about?
We are bottom five, pretty sure.
No.
No, what happened?
We used to be so good at this game.
What happened to...
We were supposed to do challenges, sir, kid.
You are still doing it.
Yes, but if...
I don't know.
I have high hopes anymore.
I never had high hopes to begin with.
Yeah, I can't wait to say that actually.
I'm like low-key impressed that you said that.
Hey, Tempo, please.
Just do that.
I got, I pinged it too.
Oh my God.
Ah.
Wait, I have the perfect excuse.
I'm categorized as platform.
You guys should have been carrying me.
Of course, yeah.
This is so embarrassing.
Tempo, based on the zone, I mean, not that, I mean, no
offense.
Where do you think this is going?
should know because he watches so many scrims yeah wig you
should know okay both of you guys should know yeah why just
me i'm asleep absolutely that's true actually that's true
yeah i mean i want to go into energy depot but their team
there we should just keep walking up towards this okay i'm
following wing you you make the yellow dots and i just
follow okay yeah let's start it moving i have no idea where
the zones are going god it might be now i know why no one
picked a turbine Honestly, my loot's pretty good.
We got scammed by a sugar beacon.
Hammond, that's fine.
It's fine.
Oh, they're far.
They're far.
They're far far We're good.
I lose pretty dog shit.
I have no attachments on anything or bats.
I'm gonna get a bat right now, though I'm not great.
I'll be honest.
So you lied.
I'm not bat.
You literally said you- Did I say I was good?
You said your loot was pretty good.
Let's go energy bow.
Let's go this way.
Okay.
We're gonna move up.
Oh my god, I fucking need that.
Fuck me.
Just pick it up.
Pick it up.
Oh Yeah, just go just go just go up there.
Watch out.
Temple you go up there first and just watch out Wait,
they're fighting behind us.
Wait come back here.
Come back here.
Come back.
Oh Okay Where where where now go back up now go back up.
We're not going up Okay, okay, okay, I'm turning around.
We got a point.
We got point.
It's time to leave Oh, we're not last.
Wait, they scan for us.
We should leave.
We shouldn't be there Okay.
Go back down.
Yeah, yeah.
We're going to wait for my sublime.
We're going to go across the small building over here.
Once I come here.
Come here.
Take this.
We're not gonna die.
Okay.
I didn't hesitate.
I didn't hesitate this time.
Good.
Nice.
See, we're good.
We're going to play here in the roof.
Don't stand on the roof!
No room action.
Okay.
There's a four by...
Oh, wait, I need that structured.
He's a two by four for me.
Well...
I'm dropping.
nice well i'm dropping a 2x okay i don't need it we're good
there's a lot of people rotating in over here i'm still
where this going 42 damage and a kill i mean we're not last
we we're we're 19 and we got a point and we got a point
that's like one point right now tempo that's gonna be for
you okay okay okay we need you to get us blue armor why is
no one getting this care pack did you did you scan the care
package already i did yeah they got it they got it it's fine
that's what it is we're doing it I'm so proud of all of us
oh my god here you go you don't need a heal tempo I will
give you one little one little heal yeah great dog we're not
wasting meds alright we're good we're good we're gonna see
what the sounds are we'll make it play we'll make it play I
heard a critical clothes uh they're over here there's a lot
of people routine towards us towards us that's why i'm like
confusing where the zone's going i'm scared what if they
come to us from behind no we're fine five ten boats i want
to put some traps out here buddy like maybe a little bit
farther up yeah so we know they walk up on us yeah yeah
exactly exactly oh my god we're so smart you're getting it
now you're getting it you're understanding yeah we're
getting there figuring this out i don't see anybody yet they
kill more people so like we can be like 18th place it
shouldn't be on the room sounds so much better than 20th
it's insane yeah i know for some reason 18 place sounds a
lot better to me 26th it sounds fantastic i'll take 18
points all day oh i know i'm off me i'm not using this two
times i don't want it i have a two by four i don't need it
okay my bad should be coming by this side right i'm not
doing anything i'm so sorry i don't we don't i don't know
where to go We're good.
We just wait.
We don't.
We have we have.
I have no.
I have a Moby.
We have a Moby.
We don't have a redeploy.
I do have a Zipline.
So efficiency.
We can make this work.
18 place.
Let's go.
Green war for another.
I'm saying if it goes towards garden, our rotate through.
There's still a guy here.
There is.
Oh, I see him.
It's probably outblown.
Green Pathfinder.
That might be out.
To be honest.
Okay.
Someone type in this chat right now to not push us.
for that yeah stay still going we get some collision going
so i never i mean let me there's no rules and twitch rivals
about yeah they never said no colluding they did not say
yeah yeah yeah yeah i would see how bad my zone call was
yeah all right let's see we got scanned we're even looking
for we got surveyed over here i don't know feel free to
roast though let's see how it goes guys for legal reasons
That's a joke guys.
Do not go into it.
Because I think he'll actually push us now that he knows
we're there.
So do not go into it.
Alright, we gotta go Rift.
We gotta go Rift.
Come on, come, come on, come on, come on, come on.
And they just, a whole team just flew in.
We're so chocked.
Oh no.
A whole team just flew in this building.
And this building passed.
I want to go next if we can.
You see when we get out.
I don't want to push that one down.
Come here, come here.
Alright.
Oh, there's a team here.
Fuck me.
Go back, go back, go back.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
They literally can't go to the front.
This is how do we not have a...
I have a...
I'm going to drop down my Lifeline package.
How?
Maybe we'll get something here.
Okay, you guys stay here?
Yeah, yeah, you guys are going to get loot.
Get EvoCache yourselves.
Yeah.
I'm going to go check up on Energy Depot until we get
Rotate.
Just stay up.
Just stay down here.
One second.
Let's go about the scenes.
There was no EvoCache, by the way.
It was just...
Was there an EVAC tower on that or no?
Nope.
There was nothing.
There was a purple heavy mag.
Yay!
Just reach the enemy again.
Wait, they feel behind us!
Wait, where are you?
Where are you?
You're watching, guys.
Come over here, come here, come here, come here, come here.
Tempo, keep running, come around.
Look over you, buddy.
Come right here, buddy.
Oh, no!
Why me?
Why is it me?
I'm dead too.
It's time to go.
It's time to go wig.
Run, run, run.
You can craft this.
This is exactly why I went lifeline.
This is exactly why.
How does that happen?
How do we get walked up on?
I'm getting sent on?
I'm dead.
Bro, this is...
Who the fuck is this, man?
Bro, when are we gonna get a fucking evac?
We haven't got one evac, and we haven't got a fucking
beacon.
Wait, wait, we gotta kill them.
So it's not a zero.
We got one.
No, one kill.
Bro, not a single evac, not a single beacon.
I'm going to lose it.
I literally did not hear anything for the team that walked
up on us, too.
be fair to be crazy because that's not even the team that
killed you guys that just killed me it's a completely
different squad wait your squad is already on red with 34
damage bro that was max team too i'm so i'm so sad how how
do i how do we not get a beacon how do we not get a single
scan in three games out of command center or fucking
turbines all i'm saying is like i we need to let tempo roam
free and maybe yeah i might just make you i might make you
play a controller legend and you just literally land on a
beacon somewhere and if you make it to us by the time we get
a zone we're good we're so i swear this is like the best
strat we let him roam free you literally land on one of
those where you scan it across the map and you just meet up
with better wait what map is next then next is going to be
geyser again what guys are you bro geyser we should have a
beacon somewhere man oh no i even commandously a 90 and and
i'm losing it i'm losing it i just want to get into one
fight like an actual fight i know i want to pay to the end
game this is crazy this is insane guys okay okay temple i
believe in you to be free very free temple
i can't believe it i had I can't believe we got walked up on
and temple.
I didn't even hear anything.
We didn't hear the walk up at all I have no idea how it's
possible Release him from why is that team walking up on it?
It was max team.
I fucking knew he was gonna kill us Different fucking team.
It was two teams that pursued our building Oh my god, that's
insane now I understand sweet dreams for strays not getting
beacons.
It's nice that you're doing a watch party and own
tournament.
I'm bad at you.
Oh my God, three.
This is like your own tournament too.
Why is your own tournament so fucked up?
Why is it so cursed against you?
Why do they hate us bro?
Why do they hate us?
That's what I'm saying.
Okay, we're back.
What do you mean we're back?
We were already back.
It can't be my own tournament and then we have a good time.
Friends, but those of you that know that we're going to have
a good time.
It's okay.
Those two teams that are winning right now, they're not
having as fun as we are do you think that's actually true
though they might be winning do you believe that with their
whole chest they might be winning but they're not having as
fun as we are that could be more true i agree because
somehow i'm rage induced but i'm just having a great time
everything yeah they might win more money and be more
financially secured but what do we do we laugh but but but
homies for life actually homies like where are they are they
dead oh they go the corner yeah those teams those teams are
doing much better than us and they are winning you know they
won't be back together after this tournament also like yeah
fucking nerds a little bit of them right like yeah they want
a little bit nerds get you know yeah they're fucking nerds
how dare they be good at a video game but you know they
won't reconvene back together and do a reunion or anything
they're gonna forget each other the next day yeah but we
will we're relatable chat how did that is this making you
feel better chat yeah we're like just we're like the team
where it's like if we can be in a tournament so can you
anything is possible for you guys if they are allowing us to
play this tournament with all these pro players who are
infinitely better than us that means you can too one day
wait wait wait i'm included i don't know about it really
better i won't say though after those shots i just gave them
that was they're definitely infinitely better i just gave
them 14 warning shots
That's right.
Thank you.
You're so lampple.
Like, when the chat...
No, I'm just down to earth.
You know what I mean?
Like, you get it?
Yeah, exactly.
You're humans.
Like, when chat watches other pro players, they're like, oh
my god, these shots are inhumane.
That's what I'm saying.
There's no way he's able to...
But then when they watch you, they're like, oh yeah, he's
definitely a real person.
Like, he's...
That can be fun.
He's definitely a player.
Yeah.
From Apex Legends.
I shit just like you guys.
Yeah, yeah.
And they're like, people would be like, oh my god, he's on
controller and still missing?
So relatable.
guys i have a secret plan what's your there's two teams
contesting at harvester so what does that mean for us yeah
what does that mean for us we're literally on geyser i'm not
hurting harvester when i'm back i'm someone you see you know
exactly what the internet crash right back you know exactly
what that means what is that What the heck does that mean?
We need some KP.
There's no way we're gonna be able to get there from Geiser.
Who said we're landing Geiser?
Okay, is Temple gonna...
Temple, you can third party them for us.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Great idea, guys.
Okay, you two land Geiser and loot.
I'll land Harvester and try to sneak like a three kill or
two, and then I'll run away.
Yeah, exactly.
And then they'll...
Yeah, and then I'll loot...
and then i'll meet up with you guys at geyser no if he fails
if he fails we have we have any craft yeah we can craft him
in geyser that is so smart if you watch the advantage that
looks like us out there that was crazy i was thinking of a
strap no i had i had max pov there okay okay yeah well we'll
i mean we are sending temple out to rome so temple you're
gonna land on harvester oh my game didn't crash my discord
restart said it's so but i'm okay now yeah we have a plan we
have guaranteed one kill we're just gonna we're just gonna
let tempo roam free around the map for it i'm gonna go third
harvester and then and then suicide and then you guys craft
me a geyser and then bring me back to life yeah that's the
best plan you've ever had should guarantee us one kill Yeah,
one point is there.
And then we're back in the game.
I don't know about back in the game, but yeah.
Back in the game.
All right.
See, now I'm kind of happy we didn't play this zone again.
You know what I mean?
I think you're just coping, like.
No, never.
I think you're just coping.
No, this makes sense.
The playing this zone has been way too difficult.
I'm not kidding.
I actually went 0 for 7 on Sentinel shots to cover for you
guys.
I said I'm covering for you guys, and I did not.
covered once i'm covering we ran up we died that's why we're
so relatable thank you people watch us for the relatability
i know i'm down to earth i got it thank you yeah people are
like people don't want to watch a a robot they want to watch
somebody that can make mistakes despite how many they make.
They want to just feel like they... Is it a mistake?
When do you make mistakes?
Despite how many to make.
Look, I'm saying as a team, as a team, I'm not singling
out...
I'm not singling out anybody here, but if anyone wants to
give out examples of how they made mistakes, that's on them.
I can't think of an mistake for my end, but like oh no no no
no we never know no but like if anybody else wants to tell
what the mistakes they made that's that's totally fine yeah
tempo if you want to open up bro we're not gonna try yeah
yeah you want to open up too tempo like zero mistakes no oh
zero mistakes oh okay then we we know i like how what i was
like i don't remember my mistakes you you're like yeah
you're right and then for example it's like oh you're
delusional okay my mistakes just why can't you put that down
right out the window double moby is crazy and we can't even
find an evac fucking tower we can't even find there was no
fucking anything in my package i got purple enemy back that
was great and they got double moby and we can't find a
fucking evac unreal it's okay all our luck It's because
you're the tournament organizer.
Every fucking luck is not with us.
That's low-key true, though.
I feel like I actually cursed myself by being the organizer.
You should...
Okay, you know what was funny?
Honestly, Greek should have been a caster in your
tournament.
Honestly, they asked people on the player cast.
I don't think I regret my decision yet.
I feel like it would have been so funny that Greek would
have been so funny that Greek was a caster in your own
tournament.
And behind me, that'd be so fucked.
That'd be so fucked.
Just make him watch.
Yeah, just make him watch party.
It's just that would be so fucked.
Wait, who's team is this?
You're still casting it so far.
Wait a minute.
Ew.
Can't what?
mode they did yeah they turned me it's been on this entire
game i didn't notice and a self-revive on lifelines crazy
ggs that boy yanya will win i'm kind of happy about that to
be honest yeah you know what them winning we know the player
right yeah temple you got it not land exactly no let him
land well no because you can do you can just craft me craft
him yeah if i do it do it i'm done i'm done it's so smart
it's a smart thing we can ever do that's like guarantee one
point at least like we make sure make sure you know they're
going there though yeah i just i just need a fuse no he like
analyzed he analyzed the situation he okay yeah yeah looked
at all the drop spots and there's all right yeah yeah he
made a spreadsheet and everything but how many games is this
is this like six games or five games we got three more to
get six games okay this plan should work three more to get
uh oh boy 25 points.
So we need 8 a game.
Wait, Gen is going.
Harvester.
Wait, he's going Harvester.
Okay.
I think that's one of the teams.
Someone else is going Harvester.
Yanya and...
Yanya and who?
Wait, who's Gen?
Where's Gen?
Where are two Harvester here?
Where's the two Harvester team?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Yanya and Gen.
shit i'm gonna be like we're landing harvester too no no no
no no give him no no no no no no let's send him by himself
bro yeah yeah please be okay okay okay okay wait wait for
the legends yeah i should be able to throw like a million
nades at them and just run away no you're supposed to get
one kill you're supposed to yeah yeah million nades one or
two kills and then run away you're so confident in game bro
you need to die yeah no i i'm gonna because you're not if
you if you die by the time we're leaving geyser then we
can't craft you i gotta loot no name so i'll i'll kill them
and then oh wait oh i'll kill all of them and then just loot
all of harvester myself exactly you go in there and just
guarantee a kill it doesn't matter yeah yeah yeah you just
guarantee a kill for us i'm catching fuzzy what are you
saying in the chat bro there's no fuse pathfinder octane
bloodhound rampart catalyst all right so obviously i'm
playing I guess I'll play either Loba and Newcastle.
Which one should I do?
I feel like we're always poor on loot.
I feel like...
Yeah, yeah, definitely.
I agree.
I feel like we have been getting...
Doing really well in the loot department.
Just saying.
I'm just saying.
Yeah, I mean, what dickhead put us on this?
Oh, wait.
This is the one game that doesn't have an assault.
No.
That's fine.
You don't need it.
All you need to do is just kill them.
That's really it.
No, no, wait.
If you're dropping over there, we need the ring.
But you're going to have to wait for you to craft it at the
ring.
them and then do the ring at harvester i'm just so
optimistic i hate it okay let's do it yeah okay i'm down
this is what our brain is telling us we need a rubber to
listen to our brain yeah rampart or catalyst then well
that's on you guys i'm i'm good with my choices increase who
are you going for left and then who are you playing joki i'm
playing i'm playing loba for the loot right because we're
always poor yeah yeah i'm gonna play octane we're always
broke we're what do you mean we're so broke all the time
this is it this time no i actually think this is the one i'm
not kidding no this is the one 100 dude wait wait since
you're you're you're the headliner right can you make them
make up an award for us like the most the happiest team or
something the happiest team first gotta be a little bit
happier than first right Okay.
I'm not saying my happiness levels are down, but you know
what I mean?
The most fun team.
That one we take.
The teams are the best vibes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Tell them.
Tell the Twitch Rivals staff to pick.
You know what the Golden Cockies?
Yeah.
They should nominate us.
The Golden Cockies?
What is that?
Golden Cock?
What is it called?
The Golden Pants?
Like the Pants.
What is it?
caught us.
Cackies?
Yes, cackies.
Is that how you pronounce it?
The golden cockies.
They had to nominate us for the golden cackies, and then we
win by sheer popular vote.
Unless Hal is in there, so obviously we're not going to win.
Oh, no, no.
Your V-Tuber army wins.
No, no.
I think I think.
Yeah.
I don't know about that.
You didn't have time?
Yeah, there's time.
Okay, I'm going, I'm going, I'm going.
Oh, my God, I got tea.
Okay.
Who is everyone running?
It's okay.
They're not going to start the game.
You're not going to start the game.
We're so fine.
Yep.
Oh, my gosh.
All right.
So the plan, tempo.
You.
All right.
Harvester.
You die.
I wish I had a fuse, but yeah.
a kill wait what are you playing in cat but but if i get a
kill and i can run i'm gonna run through no name and then
meet up with you guys to wherever you run because no one's
looting no name okay but like wait wait how do i land in
harvester degree yeah i was gonna say how are you gonna how
are you gonna get to us y'all can just punch some oh no wait
no i can't you're gonna don't punch I was gonna say punch
them into the lava and then block them with rampart punch
them into the lava and then block with block them with
rampart walls Bro, just don't
Tempo your only job Do what you can to get a kill do not
trip that is your only mission That's really it I believe
you you Tempo I believe in us.
I can't believe our first team was our peak.
I can get I can get two kills.
Wait, what's the good news?
Greek isn't last with us.
Wait, we're last two?
Wait, that's good.
No, that's good.
That's good.
The score.
Wait, Greek.
Greek has four points.
Wait, who's Greek up?
Wait, we have five points.
Yes!
You know, he's guaranteed last.
Oh my God.
It's the best MRI.
Okay, perfect.
Oh, my God, it's amazing.
Wait, who's Greek with?
Timmy?
Reptar, Reptar and, uh...
Did Reptar pick first?
Yeah.
Doki just exploded.
Wait, what about landing tunnel that's close to the balloon?
What is, what's tunnel that's close to the balloon?
Wait.
In, in, uh, Harvester.
Are you picked first, though?
How did he...
It's the curse.
I can feel the curse.
there's a tunnel?
Oh, it started.
You guys have your picks?
I have my pick.
Wig?
I bet you Wig ran into Gick.
Wig, we can't have minus five.
We only have five points!
Who am I playing?
I thought you were playing Octane.
Yeah, man, man.
Yeah, I'm playing Lobo.
Yeah, I got cat.
I was going to say, we literally only have five points.
We can't have a minus five.
Yeah.
I mean, even if we got 10 points here, we're still bottom
five.
Wait, what?
Where are you seeing the scores?
The Google Sheet thing isn't updated.
I'm just guessing.
I'm guessing here.
Oh, okay.
Bro, what happened to us?
We fell off, man.
We were never on.
What do you mean we did so well?
We fell off of.
We did so well as rivals.
What happened to us?
Temple drop alone.
Watch this.
Redemption round.
Temple's going to kill it right here.
Okay.
Temple, just remember.
Just leave us.
Remember to solo.
You can pick a big pathfinder, not Octane.
It's fine.
Octane.
Pathfinder is fine.
Is Pathfinder the thingy?
Oh, it is.
No minus five.
Jesus Christ.
Oh, my God.
There's no zero points.
Holy fuck, dude.
Oh, my God.
Goodbye, Tempo.
Goodbye.
Oh, my God.
Thank God.
Pathfinder's choice, chat.
We're good.
Yo, they see one random person just flying.
Yo, there is a contest here.
Oh, my God.
Yes, there's.
I see the contest.
Oh, my God.
They're landing on each other.
go off me i'm gonna go left here okay okay they're literally
landing on each other tempo i am waiting for that i am i am
wait there's no fucking stance on us anyway so we're fine
i'm dead wait what wait what no i'm okay i'm alive oh my god
there's no there's someone landing inside the no name okay
okay you scared the shit out of me there that's the shit out
of me too yeah wait enough they're not fighting how about
you need to die you guys have beacon over there no of course
not no we need you to die brother we need we were solely
dependent on you dying here yo i got his beacon i'm running
back to you i'm stealing their loot and i'm running with
their beacon i thought they're contesting what happened they
are they're contesting very far away oh oh okay very far
away it's okay i i got we have gods we can get a god spot
here guys oh we're so we're zone yeah we have zone we have
zone on us how do you know i'm running i'm running we look
at the zone look at the zone it's to pull up towards
overlook side we got skin what now they're gonna think we're
too oh no that's gonna actually run up on us oh my god
they're gonna send us i will bet my entire life they send us
our whole plan was for tempo to die but yet he's still alive
i left i left this this house for you except for except for
the helmet it's fine i'm more focused on these guys actually
coming to kill us in the end i'm trying to be funny what if
like tempo is the one that crafts us in the That would be
actually so, that would actually be poetic.
That would be so sad.
Oh, I have a havoc turbo.
Now we won.
Okay, I have a R9 bolt.
I'm only short ring.
I'm going to craft a bat.
All right, Teppo, are you okay?
Yeah, I'm going to eat.
I'm going to eat.
Okay, I'm going to craft a bat then.
making sure we're not getting sent on we're okay right now
we're good yeah we're okay we need to get the zone though
tempos so get over here quick and we're gonna go yeah i'm
here now we're gonna get inside overlook somewhere i just
don't know where the zone's exactly ending that's my evac
whoo i have an increased range for my ult i can all whenever
but i'll wait a little bit i'm evacing to you yeah come on
wait he's with evac to us that's fine we're here that's a
guy whatever wait are we staying here no we're going we're
going okay i'm coming over you up towards overlook for sure
that's where it's gonna end okay any of that fucking up top
any of those houses up top bro we are vibing like we're
actually chilling okay we can get ratted on here pretty hard
so gotta watch out we have no scams and team's gonna have
bloodhound so let me go first and whatever happens uh just
run away and craft me all right i'm like giving you the lead
here i'm like i'm not kidding at any moment if you think
we're losing this gunfight you guys run i don't care if i'm
not what if that's every moment that's great who looted
inside here i did i did i have an extra battle style you
guys are far okay wait okay i was gonna say i can loot the
vault right now oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm gonna look
the ball yeah do it do it watching i'm watching this thingy
i need to close my blanche i actually can't see all right
yeah i was gonna say where the did you go all right let's
see i'm gonna grab I'm going to grab the knockback shield.
Yeah, knockback shield.
Never heard of that.
Let's do it Knockdown knockdown I got the knockdown shield
guys if you guys get down I have gold if you get knocked
just you get back up Yeah, it's a knockback.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right, keep on moving.
Keep on moving.
We're good.
I'm right behind you We're doing great guys seriously not
last 90 plays beach placement is an improvement wait don't
come over here wait wait okay okay come go go we're good
okay i'm putting all my trust in you i shouldn't but like
don't do that don't worry i'm gonna give you more pressure
um give me comments real quick one sec can't tell there's
someone here or not i cannot do i don't think so i don't
think so i'm gonna go on i'm gonna go on height i'm gonna go
on height okay i got scanned up over here yeah we're good i
gotta hit peek in here too we're gonna play back here and
hit the beacon late okay okay how about he's right here
tempo you have anything you should this go with yeah can we
climb up there no we can't we can like be on the ledge here
I think I need a zip line though yeah we need a zip line
here you guys can get over here to zip line I want to put it
down below like yeah and we're here yeah come over I have
20% on just stay up here for now just put up did you put
Kacus over your time boat all uh yeah I threw one up over
there yeah we're gonna do that for right now right this is
ramparts the teams are definitely think it's any here for
sure hey
I have only short range Okay, I have long range I'm good I
have flat I ping the long bow and stuff Yeah Good I already
have one I'm showing Yeah, yeah, but for tempo I meant Let
me check if there's any sniper Oh, there's sniper ammo here
If you need it Oh, I might take afterwards Yeah I'm just
gonna put it on this side I want to make sure no one pushes
us Do you fucking Shoot Poking them with a fucking Okay One
sec i'm gonna do this for you guys one second you guys stay
there okay all right i'm gonna do this for you all just in
case you want to come up here yeah yeah yeah i wanna be free
and i'll play i'll play the other side though you can go
from there i'll be here yeah you're good nice they're
fighting over here they're fighting like how hard how hard
hard fighting they just into each other they kill each other
yeah yeah we they're into each other yeah i don't think it
was a way for us to get there yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna put a
low ball right here so see if there's a Go for it.
I'm gonna hit the beacon when it's closest.
I have my zone thing now.
So we're good to go.
There's a oh there's snipers for you.
There's snipers.
154.
Okay.
And there's sniper scopes.
There's sniper scopes.
Dubs, you can do this.
I hit those.
I did my upgrade.
I'm going to perk.
Someone someone get the stuff before it's gone.
Before someone shoots it.
Look at the zone.
When you move up, we need to move up.
Oh yeah.
All right.
We need to take more space in zone.
we're gonna get this house right here okay all right i'm
heading over to you yeah you're good just we get in here
we're vibing make sure we okay now when we're in this house
we 100 can get sent on just play slow all right my cue takes
someone behind us yeah there's people behind me there's
people behind me can you cover me yeah you're good i'm
looking for you i'm looking for your body i don't want to
die through the window i'm here you're good you're good
you're good you're we're vibing we're vibing i'm vibing i
could have queued but i didn't because i had more confidence
in you guys as a team oh that was thank you i think we're
good i had a lot of confidence in all of you to protect me
so i never queued i would definitely queue me and we're not
good that means i trust my homies get your homies my life is
in your hands that's too much i don't even know where i got
shot at we'll get farmer guys oh right here on Okay.
But the zone's actually not bad for us.
We're fine right now.
We're doing pretty good.
Anyone in big house over your tempo?
Do you know?
I'm going to check.
You guys stay there.
Whoa.
Now I see it.
Now I know what you guys are talking about.
No, we'll get here.
I mean, they might be routing it, but I think they sent it.
I'm going to go in here one second.
Just wait.
Just wait here.
We can't craft you if you die.
I know.
You're good.
There's no one in here.
Come with me.
You might need that tempo.
You need what?
Who am I?
I'm good.
I'm okay.
How does she fucking do it?
I'm losing so many cells.
It's crazy.
I'm just gonna not peek anymore.
I'm good.
We're good guys.
We're all good.
I don't know how the fuck we did it in here, but we did it
guys.
I don't know how I live that, but let's go.
Oh, I'm very proud of you.
Good shit, guys.
Okay.
Are you sent on?
Are you team on us now?
Underneath our house.
Underneath us, which is fine.
Okay.
I put a Loba stick on the door.
They're shooting my stick, but that's okay.
I grabbed some stuff before they could.
If you guys want more ammo, there's some here.
I'm just going to...
Oh.
We don't have enough meds.
Don't peek too much.
You guys can grab ammo here.
Oh, there's 39 shells.
Oh, my God.
I'm chilling out.
cells i'm so stupid okay with the next one you're good oh
yeah that's right all right you're at tim you want to pick
you want to do the thing yeah one sec i gotta go out 39 33
cells is gigantic for us yeah that's so nice good call on
the loba dude i told you i know because we're always poor
every game we have to play loba to have to have anything in
life wig what's up oh i'll take that if you don't need it
yeah i i got the charge right now i'll put the next one here
you need a sniper ammo buddy i can give you something i need
i got it i picked it all from the uh thing all right big dog
let me know if anymore it's loot time loot time my existence
is to just sit here because i don't have any range yeah
you're good just a team underneath us make sure we just
don't get walked up on yeah i'll aim up this window at them
wait they're on Okay, I'm going to say, I feel like they
might low, like, they might, they might rampart our door.
Honestly, that being on the roof is pretty good for us.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're carrying, they're, they're like, they're like our,
our wall.
How is this guy walking up if there's a team on our roof?
They're breaching.
As I say, they're not going to push us and this team just
literally sits there for free.
That's crazy.
They have their priorities.
Oh yeah, we're locked in.
We're so good guys.
We got good spots.
Look at us.
We're fucking killing it.
We just need a team to die around us.
That's what I'm saying.
Now, we're going to get so much loot.
We should be good for next zone.
I'm pretty sure the next zone is going to pull towards us.
Yeah, me too.
I think.
I could be wrong.
I'm just going to believe in you.
Thank you.
That's actually the nicest thing you ever seen.
I've always believed in you.
Thank you so much.
Like, why is Webby and CC with you for seven, maybe
hypothetically, seven hours?
This guy's just out in the open.
Three and a half hour.
He's just out in the open shooting.
I don't know how he's doing that with the team.
on her roof yeah that's what i'm saying i'm confused they're
not looking at him which they might be the knockers to be
honest the hundred percent yeah okay a little horny yeah how
is this team on the roof not shooting these guys and what's
this the third on a roof i'm gonna grab this army and then
also these shields oh my god bro that's so the cells are
such a a vibe saver it's crazy good shit let us go all right
we can't kill us because we're all we always have unlimited
cells this this has to be his teammate that's on a roof
there's no way these guys are able to peek this yeah i'm
pretty sure yeah i mean this guy is just in the open in the
open this is crazy if anyone who the hell would run new
castle and this might be someone with a lot of someone
that's not geyser for poi and someone that's very confident
in their ability Yeah.
Oh, they take this.
One team, an RV.
Oh, nice.
Oh, my gosh.
Flesh.
That team should die.
There's no way someone's going to let them do that.
Whoa.
I think they're doing it right now.
They are doing it.
They're good.
They're chilling.
Let's go.
Guys, guys, guys.
We got to hold it down here, guys.
I've never been top 10 before.
I'm there.
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait.
Don't chase it.
genuinely genuinely if we get sent on and people are trying
to push in our building we do not contest we back up here
and throw grenades here yeah yeah yeah i'm being so serious
i'm so for real right now i'm not even trying to be funny i
opened their door all right and also just keep instant oh
they might be wait does the real part does sheila break
through cat door or no yes yes yes they can yes it does yeah
that's why i was like be careful I heard that wide up and
I'm scared now.
I heard the wide up.
The wide up is giving me a fear.
Alright, also just keep instant dropping your lowball to
wherever you get it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
20%, 20%.
Where's this care pack at?
Can I scan those again?
Oh, we don't need beacons.
We don't need all those fucking ring scans.
Oh, you end up getting a actually end up getting a charge
rifle that's great it was in this room we just got to make
sure we like tembo if you just get sent on it's like
literally just walk back yeah back up yeah i have another i
have another low ball oh nice nice that's great more people
are going to die near us too this is fantastic yeah i'm
grabbing i might actually just take grenades there's your
grenades you know there are yeah there are there's there's a
lot for her yeah i took two grenades i'm just gonna put them
on the ground if we need them we're definitely not gonna
need We should be fine.
Yeah, we just need nades.
You guys are just picking up the nades that you threw down.
Oh my god.
I'm like, oh my god.
I'm like, why did we pick up the grenades we dropped?
I'm chipped to my stomach, dude.
Fuck me, man.
Yeah.
Okay, that's pretty funny.
Honest, honest, watch out.
We're gonna leave.
No, it's a Sheila.
It's a Sheila.
Take that door.
Take the door.
Okay.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna collapse the door.
i'm gonna look for picks here on the back side just make
sure there's no one i'm coming i'm looking with you just in
case we're good yeah we're vibing top 12 guys zone are we in
all right guys don't bear we're in we're in this corner
we're in this corner we're playing that corner we're playing
that corner we're playing that corner and we walk out late
we're gonna show no presence once the zone posts the only
way they know we're here is from our lowball that's that's
fine i need i need to get purple bro for a zip line really
bad we gotta get purplier There's a guy there's a new castle
behind his wall.
Alright, we got scan from behind.
There's a new castle right here behind this.
He's just...
Oh, he's rotating to the left.
Oh, I couldn't see him in time.
It's a little rat.
He's a little rat guy.
It's a little rat guy?
Yeah, he's a little rat.
He's ratting up there.
I have Loba all in 20.
We're good, we're good.
We're doing great.
We're doing great, guys.
Oh, my God.
I need my zip line here, so we take less damage on zip
really bad.
I need to get this purple.
Yeah.
Fuck me.
I missed the shot.
Being a major guy on the roof.
Oh, my God.
Let's fucking go.
Holy shit.
All right.
Oh, my God.
I want to shoot this guy so bad.
I was a little baller.
All right.
We're still on this corner.
Yeah, we're good.
We're good.
Just keep holding.
Literally make sure that no one pushes the door.
That's all we need right now.
Okay.
Just make sure we don't get shield in the back late.
Yeah.
I'm looking.
I'm looking for you guys.
We're good.
I'm going to keep staring here too.
One second.
I'm going to keep looking at the door.
I'm looking at the store just in case.
Yeah, you guys look forward.
I have all here, I'm gonna put buy all of it right here.
Never got in the position fully.
That guy's a beast.
Actually, the plan is so fast.
All right, I'm going to back here.
Just keep on this door.
There's a red for us here, if you need it.
Oh, nice.
Yeah, yeah.
Refresh, refresh it.
You should refresh it.
It's a refresh, not a natural red.
Yeah.
Grabbing two more grenades.
Yeah, I'm gonna take.
I am going to grab...
Or do I need batteries?
No.
We're good.
We just play that corner, guys.
We're just gonna play that corner.
We're gonna need them too.
How in are we?
Fighting in that room.
Kind of.
Tempo, you gotta stay in this corner.
We're good.
We're gonna zip out late game somewhere.
Give a lot of room, actually.
Wait, are we gonna die in here?
No, no, no.
We're good.
We're gonna walk out late.
We're gonna literally walk out late.
Okay.
Only one of us can peek at a time.
I'm not even kidding.
I'll peek.
Yeah, yeah.
We will peek.
He has the armor.
He's one shot.
jump again you little bitch guys I have 56 damage nice job
I'm contributing all right what we're gonna do here guys you
see this little clip here late game we're gonna go to this
cliff here late okay okay we're gonna literally walk out
left we're walking to front door and we're gonna go out to
look outside okay we're gonna have to go pretty early though
cuz we can't fucking get killed fucking through storm I
believe I'm gonna need I need to grab this museum then wait
is because we can have like that one second he shield they
do the turn oh it's tournament mode we gotta uh uh wait six
seconds okay we're gonna go now go now go now go now go to
clip go to clip jump to clip side right here on me right
here come here we're good we're gonna look left we're gonna
look left immediately look at these kids they're gonna try
to shoot us okay they're gonna be kids right above us too no
we're good we're good we're good we're good we're good we're
good we're good we're good we're so good we're so good just
stare left someone's still loving me i'm staring i'm staring
i'm staring you're good you're good we're gonna walk in late
He's gonna walk in late.
We can't really get much here.
Oh my god.
How's there six teams still alive?
We're killing more of here.
We're moving over on the team on my right on here.
Shoot the judge.
Yeah, I'm shooting.
I'm shooting.
We're good.
Shoot left.
Just the only team I can kill us right now.
Tempo is not shooting left.
I'm watching.
No, he's doing good.
He's doing good.
It's fine.
If someone walks behind us, they're idiots.
They shouldn't.
Yeah, I'm watching behind us.
Okay.
Look at looking.
Look at there.
Oh, looky.
I want to.
Yeah, they're looking.
No, bro, right when I start looking.
I said they're looking.
Why would I stop looking?
I threw, I threw.
No, I threw.
I threw.
Of course I threw.
And I got wooden.
I'm gonna throw.
You guys thought it.
The moment they stopped looking.
I saw like a fucking car salesman.
It pushed.
The timing!
And now my camera fell!
Not my camera's on the floor!
My whole setup just fell!
Bro, Wink, I don't, I think today's just not your day.
I think today is just not your day.
Oh my god, he died to me!
Oh man!
Guys, it's okay, we got six guys.
That's a lot of points!
oh what are the points that's we got six we got six guys
guys you're fucking through that man i'm sick to my stomach
too okay we're back i have to go pee like every 15 minutes
why what's that's not healthy that's not healthy at all
that's not there might be something wrong energy drinks i
just have to keep being what god what bro you must be super
dehydrated that is not healthy top six top six is not bad
how do i not get one time six is pretty decent that's eight
point we're at eight now yeah eight points yeah we got eight
points in total wait how do you uh storm wait you are ass
Why?
What did I do to knock?
Do it.
No buzz.
What did I do to knock, bro?
Wait, where's Greek?
Okay, Greek is team 14.
Team 14.
Team 14 got 19 placed with zero kills.
So they're actually last last.
Oh my god, they're probably molding right now.
I'm so happy.
Bro, they're actually last last.
We're not last because we got points replacements.
That's so good for us, dude.
My camera is so fucking busted.
box right now it's okay my goal 10 or 7 is just this is
crazy dude all right new goal not last that's my new goal
that wasn't last we did it yeah yeah yeah we got it we got
it as long as greek's team does not have does not have a
winning game we're fine i'm saying that's why i really care
about this is that yeah yeah is that not winning your
roommate doesn't win at all is that is that is that what you
want you can explain to you right when i looked away they
pushed yeah i know i was like where did you go and i looked
back at you or god i fucked it up so bad i was like wait
where did you go where did my other the other person go and
he said this is the only angle that matters and then i
immediately i immediately just looked at the other team
i just completely blacked out because i just saw a full
three man in the back i did like 800 damage to him too that
was crazy oh i got too horny this is what it is all right
wish it's top six next one's top five yeah is that how math
works next one's top five yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah we got
this okay command center was snipes team jurassic is open
there's two teams contesting storm catcher.
Jurassic's terrible, bro.
So do we want Jurassic balls?
Oh my God, Jurassic's so bad.
Isn't it like Jurassic like way worse loot than anywhere
else we can go?
But on this map that I googled, on this map that I googled,
it has a beacon.
That means we've got a beacon.
So we're not contested at Jurassic if we go there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Because somehow we still didn't have a beacon at Geyser.
Let's do it.
Let's just go Jurassic.
If we go Jurassic and there's a beacon at command center
well no there's a team command center too yeah that's fair
okay let's go to jasmine no drown don't no no this is it
wait wait wait what what what happened i'm gonna i'm gonna
do the same thing uh can we is there can we is there a
crafter at jurassic i mean temple we got nothing out of you
doing that yeah we got we got beacon i stole harv i scanned
harvester's beacon when I ran back.
But if we have beacon here, we don't need to.
So let's see first.
Let's see first.
All right, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then if not, I'll go third stone catcher, scam beacon,
and then die.
Oh, yeah, yeah, because we have crafter.
We have crafter.
Yeah, and two teams are contesting as storm catcher, so
we're good.
It's the exact same plan.
Yep.
This is it.
Yeah.
Okay, wait, okay, so what are the legends?
What are the legends that are...
Or played?
Because, like, our strategy also relates...
eyes on what legends we can play too no I think like letting
tempo be free actually made our gameplay so much better I
think so too I just don't have to worry about him yeah we
don't have to worry about him we just have to let him we
just have to free him then roam around then do what he wants
to do oh man it's okay guys we're not last what travels is
rating and also just giving 25 subs to whoever a random
streamer involved that's pretty cool oh ballistic wraith rev
valc cat mirage okay so clearly wick should play val no wait
there's a there's a fuse in there too clearly i think a
unanimous decision for this squad is that tempo is not on
valves yes yes the moment tempo was on valve we got 20th
you're still right you're still right okay and then tempo
will play callus right and then i'll mirage for the crafting
i think you're playing garage for sure we need to crash
though no are you comfortable on mirage oh yeah i'm very
comfortable on mirage why why are you so why do i not trust
what she's saying i'm so comfortable oh yeah i'm comfortable
i'm so worry when you see my banner you'll understand it
also has zero kills no no no no no no no no look at my
season five win i'm so comfortable on mirage when it was
season five when it was see okay he's at five okay she's in
21 check my check my mirage yep check it i'll check it when
we go in there check it i'm actually so mad at myself it's
unbelievable that i looked away
what is wrong with me what am i doing i said i can't blame
tempo you know i can't you can't you can't blame me looking
away.
I fucked up.
You know what I mean?
I got too horny.
I just got way too horny for the squad.
I saw Ray.
Whoa, what the fuck?
You're like, I can't, you're Mike.
What the fuck?
You're just, oh no, it's all going downhill.
It's all going down.
Oh my God.
Well, I still don't know why Knob called me ass.
mirage stats oh there we go no are you live right now no no
check that look just there we go press f what f wow i've
never seen that before oh my god you have 3600 kills i do
have so many mirage look at my wait what's mirage's thing
look at my wins i i can't believe you played that
in season five and then I never touched Mirage again.
I was on the Mirage leader points for season five.
Oh my God.
I was like, I was, I had the most, I was like top 10 Mirage
players because of my Mirage wins.
I was like number one in Canada because I had the most
Mirage wins in season five.
Who the fuck are you?
Why are you in Canada?
It's season five.
Because I had the most Mirage wins.
It's legit.
I remember it because I thought it was so funny when I
looked at the leaderboards.
I mean, that is for you being top in Mirage wins is pretty
fucking funny.
I'm expecting a carry.
A Mirage carry.
In Canada.
Great score is updated.
Once out, we're back real quick.
it's not updated that's right number one in canada that's
all that matters i was top 10 in the world for mirage wins
we're in 18th guys we're doing it we're doing it all right
we need we need we need to get the top 10 okay i don't okay
i just want it okay if we get 17th or 16th i'd be happy
that's really it I no we need we need to get around top 10
like this is sort of telling me how it's gonna be in CC
right now I'm sort of having a feeling where we're at as CC
like CC will be much easier I'm back how we looking how we
look CC people actually scrim like you see will be easier
people in CC actually scrim I actually no I think I think I
think she's yeah wait they shoot like they're not playing
with a mouse yeah like Doki you're gonna like tap strafe on
kids it's gonna tap strafe on kids on the daycare and do a
super glide on the play sets oh my god no no like in like in
challenge circuit like even i should be able to 1v3 some
teams you know what i'm saying like that's that's what
that's the vibe that you know do i have the confidence to do
so no but i would try this is our warm-up this is it hey
remember drastic if there's no beacon i'm gonna go third
steal their beacon yeah i mean i'm some for some reason this
is like an actual unbelievable strap we're doing and it's
working so we just got top six with you landing harvester
and us landing geyser i'm not really sure i've ever seen
that strap before in any level of apex legends my mom's
calling me one second yeah what's up mom hey mom mom hi mom
donkey donkey says hi what'd you say Hey, mom, do you think
I'm better than your son?
Doki wonders if you think she's better than me at Apex.
I don't know.
Bro, she doesn't even feel like...
You would tell Angie and her screaming laughing and just
look like she's like the best thing that ever...
Bro, I'm the best things that ever happened.
I hope I get to meet her one day.
She's awful.
No, no, no, no.
What?
Well, now you have to come to land.
I'm the best thing that ever ever happened to Apex.
All right, we're in game.
I love you.
Yep.
Yep, yep.
Bye, mom.
I love you.
Oh, my God.
I got the mom wing.
Wait, who am I playing?
Who am I playing?
You're playing Val.
Of course you're playing Val.
Yeah.
I'm Kat.
I'm Mirage.
Where's Valque?
Valque is top right.
Top right.
I knew it.
I knew I was special.
Left, right, middle.
Okay.
All right, let's lock it in.
Here we go.
We got this.
Yeah, I got this.
Tempo is not on the character that I'm on, which is great.
Where?
Look at it.
409 season five apex wins.
Why is it like so, so like, yo, we have beacon and
commitment.
Oh!
Okay, then you have to land on us.
You have to...
We're so good.
Yeah, you land with us here.
Yeah, now you actually land with us.
Wait, can we...
We can't...
We can't do the double scan thing, right?
No, it doesn't work.
You can scan right now and then scan afterwards too.
But...
I mean, there's no point in scanning now and after this.
We just wait.
Yeah, yeah, you just gotta wait.
I'm just gonna land here, I guess?
Sure, buddy.
Wait, why does that team right above us seem very close?
Wait, what?
Oh, where?
boy that's not my decoy by the way because i forgot to use
my decoy mirage player you should have sent it at echo is
curious on that it's gonna show yeah that's true you should
have just scared somebody just send them all into command
good game last game though guys actually like really good
yeah yeah the loba pick was was definitely the thing to do
yeah yeah i agree good job proud of you yeah no problem oh
my god i have my heirloom too Oh, nice.
Yeah.
This is one of those heirlooms I actually paid money for.
Do you like that?
Yeah, I think the Mirage statue is like one of the best
heirlooms they have.
Like, I love the animations on it.
I heavily relate to Mirage.
You love yourself that much.
I heavily relate to a guy that carries a statue around.
Yeah.
he's the actual goals you know yeah 100 tempo hit that
beacon baby let's see where we're going don't forget i have
alcold here soon did you lose this already you lose this
house oh i did yeah okay i'm going back then you're good i'm
gonna hit this uh oh we can get a good spot bro we get a
good spot guys okay i'm gonna i'm gonna immediately hit this
goddamn old excel and we're gonna get going okay we're gonna
start moving Okay guys, deal.
All right, I'm here.
Through here, right?
You guys are coming back this way.
I'm gonna come here.
Yeah, I'm gonna come back to you.
There's a disruptor here with an alternator.
Oh shit, that's probably the better one I have.
It's okay, no big deal.
Oh, okay, I could have got back.
No, no, it's like right below you.
Wig, it's right below you.
Oh really?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But where?
Oh, down here?
Yeah.
It's next to an alternator.
Oh shit, yeah, you're right, what the fuck?
Yeah, I told you.
Oh my God, that's fucking coded.
Thank you.
See?
I'm a good person.
yeah sure all right i was i'm gonna have ulti in a little
bit we're gonna we're gonna probably ulti first then evac we
want to get for this zone i think we want to get one of
these two houses back here oh yeah if it's open we're gonna
keep moving up we're gonna go through power on a little bit
more than we're gonna back with you right here up top i
don't know how far we can actually go though right behind
you i still need to see uh hey like a scope we need we need
like yeah i was zero let's go wait we can grab this thing
yeah we have to grab the yeah yeah we'll definitely do that
we need that really bad you need purple energy uh purple
yeah i do i do nice but you didn't even have energy gun wait
i don't even see this looted in an alt decoy reduce oh
that's a revive with health okay yeah that was a revival
there's a pack on her right did we want to stop for that or
no no i think we just yeah we have to get get a zone someone
definitely landed here though yeah yeah don't worry my
mirage clone will distract him good we're gonna try to get
the left side tree and ult you over okay i keep forgetting
to scan packs bro i think you won't really do that it's a
gold master i found that we need that that's fine yes fine
we're gonna tree we're gonna go to tree then ultie over oh
my god i have two four i have five needs what the am i gonna
do with five needs oh now throw them hopefully I don't know,
we have to live long enough for that.
Yeah, the chances of you throwing five is pretty crazy.
All right, ready?
Oh, my God, we're so...
What do you mean, funny?
You guys shot by a way.
It's so funny.
He got shot.
Kepler is still running here.
This could be the end of us or the start of us.
Yes, I'm Velcro.
All right, we're going to try to go backside.
Just let me know if you see anyone.
We're going for this building back here.
There's obviously somebody there.
No, I'm the building in the back.
Yeah, there's it.
There is.
We're good.
Oh, you're good.
I'm so good.
Shut up.
Using shit.
We're chilling.
We're so good.
Behind us.
Yeah, like driving behind in the open.
I want to open this bin.
See.
tempo honest question ready like giving your input do you
think that this tunnel is better for us or staying on
staircase is better i don't understand no idea it's up to
you idea zero i think we just stay here to be honest okay
playing tunnel without a without a fucking like actual good
defensive character other than the cat is pretty i'm like
i'm like 18 days for some reason all right i have like two
syringes i found single syringes anywhere
you bitch bro don't shoot me what wait my game lagged wait
what oh my Bye, bye, bye, bye.
I have a glitch.
Buys, buys, buys.
Okay, okay, okay.
I can heal.
I literally can't heal.
I have a glitch.
Wait, what?
Every time I heal, my screen goes blackouts.
Come back to me, come back to me.
Okay, okay, okay, I'm here.
I'm here.
I just threw 18 names at them because...
Yeah, you're good, you're good.
My game's fucked.
You got them too slow.
Okay, okay, okay, so you can't do that all.
I would've come back in.
I get my deal.
It like shows like, um...
Did you hit me?
Are you cheating?
Destroyer?
No.
It's an arm in my face.
I have like a whole arm in my face.
Yeah, a whole arm.
Wait, but you still can't heal, but you just, there's just a
visual bug.
I can't see anything.
I heal, yeah.
Oh, okay.
Oh, yeah.
I thought you were cheating.
My whole chat's been caught.
Oh, no, destroyer.
I'm cheating.
Destroyer.
Destroyer's here, baby.
Don't worry.
How's in our, how's in our tournament?
Destroyer.
Yeah, why me?
Why me?
Yeah, he has like so many people watching him.
Yeah, exactly.
Why me, man?
You want publicity?
Go for hell.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You'll get it.
Yeah, you'll get all that publicity.
So many tweets.
Yeah, so many engagement.
Think of the engagement destroyer.
The impressions.
Yeah, the impressions.
Oh, my God.
All the impressions.
I don't think I want to peek anymore, guys.
I don't have a lot of heals.
Good idea.
Wait, landing?
Landing, landing, landing.
Landing, tunnel, tunnel.
Tracks one.
How are you guys peeking in?
Oh boy.
The left, the right side.
Oh, okay.
They're going to be, they're going to be on silo then.
You have to watch out.
It's way slow.
Yeah, I'm just going to stay down here in the stairs.
Yeah, you're good.
I'm going to show a little breath so we don't get sent on.
My fucking Mirage clone.
Oh my God.
The fact that I can't see anything is crazy, bro.
I have, uh, 10 cells, two cats.
There you go.
He's just going to stand there and he'll let us know.
Yeah.
Actually, good comms.
They'll be like, what is this Mirage doing in the open?
Dude, this is going to fuck me over so hard if he actually
play this like this would be so bad i literally can't heal
mid-gun fight it's crazy bro they i why nerf us yeah what
are your luck today man if you if you rejoin is that do you
think that would help bro if he does that he's gonna fucking
like we're gonna have a team push just the moment he does
that i think i think if i leave it doesn't fix anything i
think it's just official bug in my game also i don't want to
risk it because whatever just gets sent on and i'm just gone
i'd rather yeah yeah shoot my clone he's literally having a
fun time in the open he's real i imagine that's just you and
they're not shooting you because they think it's a clone oh
my god i should you guys will try that hard to tell yeah
yeah you shouldn't do it right now too now okay okay never
mind it never mind it look and read through it immediately
i'm not gonna pick anymore i'm stupid bro how do you know oh
yeah i love seeing a bright yellow thing in my face this is
fire where am i i can't the syringe is half i'm shooting my
screen's covered half with the syringes it's ridiculous bro
why does no one want to shoot me please don't shoot her i
don't know if that guy is actually trying to shoot my clone
or not there's i saw straight bullets how's my clone
traveling so far oh He shot him!
He got bamboozled 50 meters away.
Get on, nerd.
Oh, I should discuss.
Okay, do you think this is a Mirage clone?
Are they gonna shoot me?
Shoot her for the scan, please.
If I died, I blame Wig because I'm doing something dumb.
Go down for that, yeah, yeah.
I'm not getting shot at.
It works!
It's fucking crazy.
They actually let me just run around.
No way.
I peeped my head through a second and got lit the fuck up.
All right.
Hopefully, guys, a minute left.
We'll see the damage.
You're on zone.
I think it's going right towards us.
I don't know if they're shooting me or what.
They are.
Wait, they are.
No!
Okay, now that I'm not doing that again.
We're good.
That I have one shield still left because I fucked around.
Don't hit me.
Okay.
I fucked around a little, so now I have one shield still
left.
Oh, nice.
How many of you have, Sambo?
I have one five now.
All right.
I am two five.
Alrighty, alrighty, alrighty, alrighty.
Let's see, let's see.
Come on, baby.
I'm real.
Chat, we think if the zone comes here or what?
I don't think so.
Come on.
Yes, you do.
Let's see it.
Pull to the other side.
Oh, Victoria.
Let's see it pull.
Oh, it's not bad.
That's not bad for us.
We're so good.
Great.
Is anyone in armory?
We're so good.
We're gonna get sent on though.
Do we just play backside rock over here now?
Isn't there people there?
I don't think so.
I mean we could.
We just hope it's all there for now.
It's all there for now.
Okay, we're gonna hold out Southwest.
We're gonna literally hold out Southwest.
It's the goal.
Oh These guys need to die on the rotation end.
Oh, I stuck my decoy in there.
I thought that was you.
Okay, so Southwest is gonna be our number one enemy here
guys.
Okay, they're gonna start cleaning us soon too.
Okay, I don't know why I want to waste some meds though.
I'm not sure if I won't waste these mids.
Yeah, yeah, Tempo, stop peeking, I think.
Yeah, definitely stop peeking, Tempo for sure.
Don't worry, I'm going to see if I can grab Intel.
I'm just peeking so I can make sure these guys know that
we're looking at them.
Well, yeah, yeah, yeah, me too.
Are they actually sniping my decoy and missing?
I think they are.
They did.
I was watching this happen.
Don't come this way, we're watching you.
They know we have to go this way, that's why.
They can go the other way.
Should we not go to the rock now, or wait?
Nah, they would just stay here for now.
I don't really want to jump too early and then we just get
fucking shit on.
I mean, we stop Valkalt.
Yeah, we do, yeah.
I just don't know if anyone's back there and we Valkalt,
then they take our spot.
It's only a problem.
Yeah, that's true.
All right, let's see where they go.
Let's keep looking over here.
Just don't take too much damage.
Someone dropped down here.
I don't know if it was that team.
they're leaving us they're leaving us and they did they want
other tunnel it's fine that's only two that left that i saw
yeah i'll three all three there yeah yeah i just saw we're
doing it look at this i just got bamboozled oh my god you
got bamboozled too where's the care pack out i need to scan
i hear a pack um to our right whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa it's fine we're good let's try it
yeah you want to do it i'll do it back bitch That clone
didn't really go anywhere.
I think that we didn't go.
There's a regular team back rock.
Knock that guy.
Hold me.
Shit, get shit on.
Okay.
I got shot from behind.
There's someone behind that rock.
They're behind the rock now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, we're good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Everybody can kill this kid.
Wait, sliding down here.
Oh, nope.
He went into that tunnel.
Let's see where the thunder goes.
He's done this pull back rock.
Where can we go here?
This is so bad for us.
Actually, holy fuck.
Well, we can't go behind this because there's a team there
now.
We can't play silo.
I don't think either.
Silo will just get shot at.
Fuck.
Yeah, they're all the way behind.
I mean, we have Velcro.
We have Velcro here.
We have to help Mary somewhere.
I think we just walk in slow and just go to Silo here.
We just walk in slow.
I'm just trying to kill everyone that's inside.
That's all we can do.
Just play slow.
Don't take any damage.
Let these teams fight inside.
We just third party and walk up.
Stay slow.
We're gonna play for the height.
We'll see if they fight inside.
They should.
Team flying in, we're good.
Yep, just get some shots down, we're all good.
Oh, they made a wall?
Oh, they cat wall.
Yeah, they cat wall.
That's fine, yeah, we're good.
They're doing something fighting whoever's there.
Yeah, just keep trying here, just keep playing there.
You guys be playing there.
I want to move up a little bit, just hold space.
Alright, alright.
We're looking.
One drop down, right here?
I'm looking.
Two drop down?
Two, yeah.
Blue armor 23?
Yeah, just keep looking there, guys.
I'm looking at something else right now.
You guys keep looking at- Picking us right now I'm gonna
kill you guys They went up They're going up They're going up
Yeah, we're good They're on the ramp Then you're gonna get
reason Why do you focus these guys?
Harcourt-leaf side I'm looking at the left Let's keep going
left I got my kill I got my kill I got my kill I got Marage
Bambo's Oh Does anyone have light ammo?
No I don't I can't spare any I knew I knew it right here I'm
gonna use I'm gonna use the other now Purple Rabbit RamRam
RatRamRam...ri consumers present right now Keep shooting
ramps Yeah.
Yeah, just keep looking left side.
We're good.
Just keep looking.
I shop, Doki, you're doing great.
We're going to move in slowly.
All right, we're going to walk up a little bit.
Come to me, come to me, come to me, come to me.
Come to me, come to me.
Come to the team right below.
There's a team right below.
They're going to fight each other.
It's good.
Come to me.
I'm here.
Follow me.
Yeah, she left.
The shoe left.
Oh, right, let's go, let's go, let's go, let's go, let's go,
let's go, let's go.
They're right behind us.
This is a mirage, this is a mirage.
Two, two, two, two.
Cratch, cratch, cratch.
Dippo, no!
You got this, buddy.
Jump down if you need.
Just play with it.
Play with it.
Play it, play it, play it.
I have a tree.
You're a tree.
I don't move.
Oh, it's just a duo behind us, man.
Oh.
It came out of nowhere.
The Valk is right in front of me.
He doesn't see me.
Just, just pretend you don't exist.
It's okay.
doing great you're doing great don't hear anything don't do
anything do not do anything they're tunnel visioning right
now top 10 top 10 good job nice we got top 10 top 10 let's
try god damn it oh yeah they actually look we got top 10
we'll take it we got top 10 that's fine i gotta pee
just to urinate again what he has to pee again you have to
pee temple what the fuck is wrong with you right here with
your body no idea i don't think that's healthy that is 100
not healthy you're peeing like every every every 15 minutes
i agree fully do nice job though we did a good job really
well played we just killed that duo we could actually be
alive right now which sucks i just they just came out of
nowhere i thought they were not rotating to us i don't know
why they that i thought they were going inside same same it
worked out but it is what is temple definitely has a bladder
problem right now for sure i'd be a nervous issue how is he
nervous yeah honestly why the is he nervous yeah how the is
he nervous he's the he's the diamond three in the game
that's what i'm saying it's okay As long as...
It's okay, we got top 10 plus 1 point.
As long as Greek got not top 10 plus 1, I'm so happy.
Yeah, yeah, that's all we have to worry about.
That's all we need.
That's all I care about.
We got the vibes.
That's all we need, the vibes.
Wow.
I'll see this play for the wraith.
Yeah, I'm checking the wraith play right now.
Oh, wait, did he get that?
He tried.
Yeah, he tried.
No, he did.
No, he did not.
Oh.
that would have been so funny that would have been so nice
if you do all the rats out here man there's so many rats oh
my god look at all these rats that could have been tempo
that could have been tempo what i can't believe you guys i
know i can't believe they saw you you could have been free
yeah i'm lucky surprised they should have been so distracted
with the people above me honestly denbo did you have cat
wall there yes i should have cat you should like we like we
go to like that pillar and we just cat wall off the other
side yeah we should yeah that's my bad i should have told
you i forgot we were playing cat we didn't use any of our
ults except for that one bell i got shot so fast i couldn't
even oh no that's not your fault either way that's my bad i
should have told like 100 tempo just to cat wall us off so
teams can't push us it's my bad yeah cat wall behind us yeah
exactly it's okay the next game now we know one kill i gotta
i gotta kill the lomba nice yeah yeah i like after that
first game temple hasn't got a big kill for more subs that
poor valk what the wait that means we're at 11 there's no uh
he tried that valk definitely tried they did their best i
listen 10th place one kill not awful yeah yeah it's pretty
decent Pretty fucking decent, guys.
You know, it means we're better than Greek.
Okay, let's check Greek score.
Oh no, I think he just won.
Imagine?
No.
Don't say that.
Don't know.
No, no.
No, we needed him to not win a game.
Please no, please no, please no.
Please no.
Oh no.
Peeps team one?
Okay, it's we the people.
It's not Greek.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
Peeps was below us too.
Oh no.
Damn it.
Oh no, oh no, oh no, oh no, wait, wait, where's Greek,
Greek, Greek's 14.
Where's 14?
Where is 14?
14, he got zero kills.
14 is placed.
Okay, zero points, zero points.
We're at six, we're at 11.
Nice, okay.
Where's Jen?
Greek team at zero points, we're still fine.
Yeah, Jen's team six.
He got ninth with two.
A little bit of a lost.
Is he going to pass us?
No, no, he was already past us, but we were going to ninth
with two.
Okay, so we're only three points a little bit.
from jen we're in 19.
it's okay we're not greek just needs a really really good
game to reptile and greek okay we just need to beat your
roommate yeah we just need to beat your bathroom i'll be
right back you're good that's all i want bro that's all i
need okay hopefully these necklacens are good for us we
definitely don't need support to be honest we haven't used
it once to be fair yeah i'm gonna go fuse if you want if she
if she wants uh controller yeah We'll see.
We'll see.
If we.
I think the next one's like pretty weird.
I think it's, uh, let me see.
I think I know they put it there.
I think it's, uh, oh, they're typing it right now.
Let's wait.
It's like six skirmisher or some show like that.
It's like majority of skirmish.
I think it was.
Wait, which was skirmisher?
Six assault.
It's six assault this time around?
I have no idea I was making it up.
Oh.
What did Clara say?
Okay.
yes who is it who is it assault controller support okay so
we have ash mad maggie ballistic watson rampart loba mirage
conduit holy um my god they really saved the worst for last
i like that uh all right so who are you gonna play i'm fused
there's no oh there's fused okay who is she gonna play i'm
back wait wait what's the what's the thing it's ash and
maggie Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can do conduit.
All right, I'm down.
Oh, it sounds great.
Okay, cool.
Yeah, I can do conduit.
And maybe I'll just do ash for the TP.
Yeah.
All right, I'm cool.
Down, down, down, down.
Yeah, so we got ash.
Wait, is Temple going to play Watson or Rampart?
Oh, actually, yeah.
I can play Watson.
Yeah, play Watson.
Yeah, yeah.
For sure.
This is the last game.
As long as Greek dies before us, then we've like established
that we're better than Greek's team.
Greek, you got to go out last.
man no do you know what's even out last what's even we have
no pro player on our team but we're still above a pro player
team yeah true if you think about it that way that you're
spinning yeah yeah we literally have why are you a genius we
basically won any team that's below us is embarrassing all
right let's pass a few more then sure that is fucking for
sure and that's gonna be one team which is greeks yeah is it
one team that's is it funnier if it's just one team yeah by
the way and rector had first pick and rector had first pick
true i'm gonna be regretting that greek decision right now
all right we'll see what happens dude all right so i'm gonna
go i'm gonna go ash then you go Watson, then you go conduit?
Yeah, yeah, I go conduit.
This is our sweatiest comp so far.
This is our actual real comp so far.
It's like the only real one that makes sense.
Alright, I swapped.
I'm back in.
Oh my god, this is it.
We're gonna...
It's not...
My goal is like...
as long as we're above greeks team that's all i want that's
all i want really all we want right now yeah yeah yeah
warm-up's done guys five world games all we needed yeah
that's all we need if if peep can go from 19th to whatever
to a win with eight yeah we should be able to do that okay
but the thing is the thing that separates us from from peep
is that all three of us are create our plat rank right now
wait plat rooting for minus down diamond raise bread yeah so
like i don't know i don't we're sort of like you know we got
this our team has to be like we're definitely the team of
the people yeah we're the people's squad the amount of
Copium we're on right now is unreal Okay, we're like no
we're the vibe team guys.
We're like we're the team that everyone likes dude We are we
can be multiple things It's not good just not good
Can you really say that we're a good team with a straight
face?
Yeah Only you can temple you're the only one he's the only
one that has like is like actually delusional.
He's the only yeah i like it though we need we need that
though we need that we need somebody that's not like in
reality yep yeah yeah yeah yeah okay well hmm all right
we're gonna this is our sueyes comp bro we win this one
there's no way yeah like we warmed up for like whatever the
game no matter last one we got this petition to play another
storm point over olympus low key down for that to be honest
petition to reset score oh my god so real no we play Olympus
we're definitely a team I know we're a team we're a team
we're a Twitch rivals and CEO of Twitch face down
all i'm saying is that wig i don't know why but when you're
headlining headlining your twitch rivals right it really
everything goes against you not everything not yet not every
though not everything though because it's not about winning
okay it's really about the friends more along the way what
yeah wait why did you argue about me about that before when
i said it wasn't about winning i'm trying to be positive now
i did point my motivations all the way through the floor
like now it's not now it's not no no of course bias you know
what i'm saying now it's not about winning all right exactly
exactly well we're up good and we haven't started yet of
course about winning but we started doing bad that's all by
the friends i can't believe our first game was our peak that
was actually the game where we had we have 11 points pretty
good just needs seven or eight seven for what that's a lot
of points we get out of bottom five we got 11 points just
from from from five games i don't know it seems like a five
game scenario
you know what wait are we leaving letting tempo roam free
again wait where are we no i can't there's there's no uh
place to roam to we're in we're in turbine yeah but like if
you survive as a solo if we're in turbine I can land
waterfall yeah yeah we should let him roam free wait should
we do it what let let tempo roam free again for last game
I'm so down okay actually tempo don't even come back to us
what's the what's the what's the the the butthole POI the
butthole POI what turbine oh oh oh um um oh fuck ripped yeah
yeah the giant the giant thick thingy what bro tempo you
organized cammon cammon cammon it has a giant giant thingy
that you go in okay do we let do we let tempo roam free and
not come back to us and then he can try and solo rat yeah i
gotta go i gotta go find a beacon yeah oh wait wait whatever
i'm still yeah i'm watching that i'm so down okay tempo
don't come back to us okay do you get a beacon and turbine
no i don't think so i'm gonna i'm gonna go steal him in okay
this is it this is the game this is the game where we get 10
points this is a game where tempo will rat until second
place or something yeah that's double our points then oh i
should pick a small person you should we already established
our pick a small person let's do it now we got this ash
right i'm ash yeah you're ash i am conduit and tempo is we
just got to trick someone into picking a character that's
not there and then they get minus five yeah but they're
gonna restart the game true but minus five they're just
gonna restart the game unless they are stubborn enough oh
there we go give me ash give me ash oh Fuck, I'm just broke
my controller.
We're good.
Give me ash.
I'm locked in.
I'm so locked in right now.
We're so locked in.
We're here.
We're ready.
All right, my face is in my screen.
Oh, hell yeah, baby.
I wish I was your screen right now.
Let's go.
Bro, what?
Can you repeat that way?
Nothing.
Lag, lag, lag, lag, lag, lag, lag.
All right, turbine, guys.
Turbine.
All right, here we go.
Do we have anything in turbine?
We have nothing in turbine.
Let's go.
we have a ring console for for temple to scan oh we're so we
do yeah we don't yeah yeah you're gonna go to hammond i
gotta wait for the team to land in hammond and then i gotta
steal their top loot someone's actually taking hammond god
bless that'll be worse than us guys i don't know we've that
person landing top hammond hey why are you still with us
stephen i forget about the strat 30 seconds Oh wait, sorry,
I was watching the other team.
Too late now.
We're good, we're good.
Come on, just stick around.
You're still here.
I came to steal your loot.
We literally talked about- Well now, don't go anywhere.
Now, play on your feet.
Just stay with us.
We're talking about the strat together.
How did you forget it?
I was, I don't know.
You're, you're, I love you.
I so much.
I hope you're getting- That's okay, Gordon.
Don't worry.
I turned around that one-night game.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't worry.
We're the team of the people.
We're the team of the people, guys.
This has to be fucking somewhere near us, dude.
Like, this needs to be near us.
There's just no way it's not.
It has to be somewhere fucking close.
It just has to be.
Where is a beacon that we can hit?
Power grid.
That's not good for us, actually.
That is not good for us.
We should not.
We should not go with it.
I think we take a gamble here.
Okay.
Yeah.
And I think we go towards docks.
Okay.
I believe in your gambles.
We have nothing left to lose.
We're literally...
We have to believe.
No, we do.
We have something to lose.
Greek, man.
Okay.
We have one thing specifically that we can lose.
We have only one thing to lose.
There's a charge rifle right here at tempo.
Oh, I got one.
Oh, go.
Nice.
He has the one thing he needs.
Wasn't there a scalper somewhere?
On the lumbar.
I don't know where the sculpture was.
I have no idea.
I haven't seen one.
They had dropped it off my repeater.
Where the fuck did I put my repeater though?
Oh my god, I'm a mess right now.
Oh no.
No, you can't be a mess right now.
You know, I'm freaking out.
I'm freaking out.
Don't freak out.
There's a repeater right here.
It's just, it's a hammer point though.
Oh yeah, here.
Okay, okay.
Found it.
I was like, good.
I'm not moving.
I'm so focused on the zone now that I just like, I'm just so
locked.
All right, let's go towards, let's go towards docks.
We don't have an evac tower.
Any evac tower friends?
Nope.
Okay, I'm going to cut you back then.
I've only had a chance to look at one evac tower and we died
really early on.
And the drop killed us.
All right.
Yeah, I'm ready.
Let's move on through, guys.
Let's do it.
Friendship.
Yay.
Hey, hey, hey.
Sound a little worse, dude.
Almost.
I love it.
We're doing so well.
I don't know.
Okay.
All right.
Keep on moving, guys.
Okay.
I'm not going to look up.
No, we're good.
We're not going to look up.
I 100% just picked the wrong perk.
We're good.
I'm looking.
Oh, whoa.
I hear an evac tower in front of us.
That's good.
On me.
I'm in.
Literally right on us.
Yeah.
Like, why me?
I mean, I'm not.
Yeah, we're good.
Keep moving.
I hear a fight to my left.
Yeah, yeah.
Just keep on coming, guys.
All right, I'm going walking forward.
I'm walking forward.
I said they're taking the thing up now.
That's okay.
We're good.
We're just chilling here.
We're going to move up.
I just want these guys to leave.
We're good.
They're leaving.
They're going up.
All right, they're leaving.
I think, no, I'm not leaving.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
What are they doing?
These guys are stressing me the fuck out.
Bamboozle.
Okay, come on me.
Follow me.
You guys coming?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's a, there's a Watson Fest, there's a Watson Fest,
there's a Watson Fest.
Come on, come on, come on, come on, come on, come on.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, go.
We gotta send it, we gotta send it.
We gotta send it, believe in me, believe in me, believe in
me.
Come here, come in, come in, come in, come in, come in, come
in.
We're good.
I'm climbing, I'm climbing, climbing, climbing, climbing.
We're good, just play slow.
We're vibing.
We can play this pillar too if we need to.
We're okay.
We're dead.
Okay, I'm going to leave.
We're good.
Okay.
I'm batting.
We're okay.
Just play slow.
Play slow.
We're fine.
There's a fence.
You are left here too.
We're vibing.
Just vibing.
We're so good.
Oh, I'm so good.
I feel so healthy.
We're so good.
I feel very healthy right now.
I'm so vibing.
It's not even funny, guys.
Oh, my God.
I'm dead.
No, we're alive.
I'm good.
No, no.
You're good.
I'm looking to my right.
Live the fuck out, bro.
I'm alive.
I'm dead.
We're okay, I think.
Oh, this is the...
I don't know, man.
I don't feel very comfortable here.
I feel very exposed for some reason.
We're going to wait for my old team to try to go up here.
Okay.
On that house.
What do you guys stay here?
I'm going to...
There's people literally right here.
Oh, my God.
What is this mirage doing?
How is he able to sit out here, man?
I'm just saying there's people right here above me.
Okay, that's fine.
We're good.
We're vibing.
We're just really loud.
Chill out.
Yeah, I mean.
I'm stressed to fall down.
I'm so stressed out.
I'm so stressed out, but we're not 20th.
We're not 20th.
That's yeah, but we need to How pro how are these kids able
to beat this?
I'm so lost how people are able to do this It's okay.
We're good.
Tembo, you're good where you're at.
You're fine.
Tembo, move up.
We're here here, right?
One place left.
Tembo just don't we're good guys.
How are these teams able to do this to us?
I'm getting harassed.
Tembo, please save us.
How are they able to get these angles?
I'm getting- Why is no one here?
I'm getting- I'm getting harassed right now.
You're good, you're good, you're good.
I'm looking for you.
I'm pre-firing, no one's there.
There's no save.
There's no silver.
There's no- I'm not- I'm not- no- no.
I'm just kidding.
We're here.
They don't shoot us.
We're good, baby.
I'm not- Do I stay here or come back?
Yeah, you stay there, stay there, stay there, stay there.
Don't stay there, don't stay there.
Come on, come on, come on, come on, come on, come on, come
on.
How are you getting shot?
Where are you getting shot from?
I don't know.
How is this possible?
No.
Everywhere I go.
There's no joke on us.
Dude, I'm so bad.
A building would be nice.
A building would be fantastic right now.
Yeah, we just take the car and eat a building.
No, you guys stay here.
I'm going to try to figure something out.
Just stay here.
This team above us must have so much space.
That's why they're doing this.
There's no way they're able to there's no way i'm so scared
man we're actually low key not awful like i'm being honest i
was literally in the worst spot possible no no this spot
where i'm at's good okay i'm genuinely i'm okay now i'm not
i'm not panicking anymore guys i've come down i've come down
oh yeah did you did you guys you just threw up everywhere
guys i'm chilling now guys it's okay guys i'm not anxious
anymore i'm okay now i'm good after all that i'm not
stressed anymore guys i think i feel like a better i feel
like a much better person
you know you know what i mean the spot is doable you know
only right now if we lay low like you guys just don't peek
no one's gonna think someone's playing yeah yeah yeah no
yeah exactly not all of these watson fences yeah who the
would play here bro yeah i'm honestly yeah yeah who the
watson fences there there's nobody here i'm gonna i'm gonna
be honest guys if there's one thing i took today from all
these games in order for challenge to work i gotta step my
eyes yelling holy yeah oh my god i am rusty i think we all
are we are all definitely rusty i would admit wait okay i
just want to know is greek's team dead is that is that i
haven't seen it i haven't seen 14 yet oh we haven't seen no
okay he's still alive it's so bad for us guys so bad he's a
lot we need to look at the only issue here that i'm the only
issue we have like genuinely is if this team above us just
the zone like pulls up more and they're the only team inside
docks then they could oh they're not they're getting shot
out that's good oh yeah that's good that's good we're so
healthy that's a great gem that's a great one everybody
knows we're here now too so that's fine that's great that's
great that's great we're creating presence now right now we
want presence yeah and now we want presence yeah like dana
yeah i'm learning i'm learning from Now we want people to
know we're here.
Yo, you're so good.
I'm just going to stay here still.
I'm going to stay here.
There's people all over the room.
We did get fucked over like pretty hard again.
Like every time.
I think like I think I think everybody bullied us out of a
good POI.
That's exactly what it is.
I think that's what happened.
Everybody just kicked us out.
They're like, OK, nice week put geyser.
They're like, I'm not sure.
All right, yeah, they could have that.
They're like, nice to have that.
They're like, all right, we'll take that for them.
And they're like, oh, it's nice to make that's on there.
Like, I mean.
They don't even have a pro on their team.
Yeah, they don't even have a pro.
They literally have a platform and a diamond.
And another plot.
I'm moving plot.
They literally had three plot players.
Okay, where's the moment of truth, guys?
Why is team 14 still?
Wait, but this is your tournament.
How did you let these people fucking...
god the zone pulls back okay this is gonna be the craziest
thing i ever said we should get middle of fight night like
inside fight night yes how do we run past everybody i mean i
get this vehicle we queue in there or i'm boosting there
okay do it now now wait okay wait wait wait come to me don't
you come over here yeah get right where tempo is okay okay i
have an ash port but i think we should go for the trident
because it's funnier okay there's he okay i'm ready christ
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go,
go, go, go.
Get out, get out, get out, get out, go, get out, go.
No, I got you.
It's a whole squad.
Why is there a whole squad there?
You run.
Get away, Doki.
Get away.
You can crack this run.
I'm getting punched already.
Why is there a whole squad?
I'm taking the port.
Oh, wait.
That's not it.
Why is there a whole?
There's not a team inside.
There's already a full team inside.
Wig, I don't think we should have done that, Wig.
Wait, where is he?
You live?
You might be able to craft that.
I'm alive, I'm alive, I'm alive, I'm alive.
All I'm saying is that, Wig, I think you might have made the
wrong decision.
I mean, why is there a full team with an Arc Star there?
Why?
Someone please tell me why.
That is unbelievable.
Wait, you have no white mats?
No!
You have zero!
Land turbine!
I have nothing!
How do you have no zero?
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
You just gotta last until 14 dies.
Team 14 dies!
Nothing matters anymore!
You did?
Nothing matters!
We're- We're- Wait, wait, wait, wait.
We can beat Deeds.
If you get- Uh, 12, 9, 7, 5.
Okay, if you get top 5, we beat Deeds.
Okay.
The second, the person above us.
Yay.
Oh my god.
The person up with a team above us and we beat.
Oh my god, the fucking riskiest reload of your life.
After the audio play, there's no idea I'm here.
You know, okay, maybe we should like not listen to something
that I was like, but it would be so funny.
Like maybe that's just not...
Yeah, but like who else smiled during that?
No one else?
We didn't.
I got stuck.
My god, I...
You got fucked already.
Wait, are you guys stuck or are our car got stuck?
Because I got hit too.
Oh, maybe our car got hit and all of us know why are you
peeking?
Why are you looking at me?
I didn't know if there's still inside fight later.
I'm going in there and scrapping.
You're literally...
Look at your heels.
The fact that you have the confidence to even look at
somebody.
At least I'm fucking dead regardless.
I'm fucking dead in this next zone for sure.
You don't know that.
oh you can craft us you can craft us in the north craft you
okay if he crafts us that's not delusional come on where is
he gonna res tempo it should realistically die to storm here
so i don't give d to kill find a movie do you know do you
know wait tempo didn't even know cc was next week he thought
it was the week after oh i thought so too oh wait what the
fuck you do I'll be good.
I thought I did, too.
Holy shit.
I did not know to play next week.
I do not have enough time to prep for that.
We are playing next week, guys.
Oh, we're so far.
We're just good.
This is good.
People are dying.
There's no one middle.
Do I go middle?
Do it.
There's heels.
There's my box on my left.
On the left.
That's me.
Right, right, right, right.
I'm nervous about them punching me in their face.
Just heal.
There's heals here.
No, you can't heal inside.
No, you can't.
Yeah, yeah.
What the fuck do you mean?
I've...
Hey, chill.
Nadi, chill.
Just leave.
Just heal.
It's you have time.
I know, but they're going to push.
They're going to come in here and bring it.
They're not going to pull.
And the other team's going to come in there.
Yeah, and then you watch these two come inside.
They scare each other out.
You're safe.
Yeah.
Yeah, there's...
No one can come in because the moment they come in, someone
else will come in.
Yeah.
It's a scare tactic.
Oh, they're just trying to scare you.
I'm fucking dead.
I'm talking dead.
I'm trying to scare you.
Oh, my God.
What the fuck just happened to me?
Stop dead!
Let's go!
You got lost.
You got lost so hard.
What the fuck was that?
What happened to me?
What was that?
I'm getting crazy, though.
Top 10 show gets me.
No, it's okay.
We're above Greek.
Oh, my God.
We actually got art in the car.
We were above Greek.
That's all that matters.
Man.
You know what crazy there?
If that team's just not there to sing with an R star, we
actually probably could get like a top five again.
Yeah, we- It's actually insane how bad our luck is.
Unreal.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm just saying, wait, the next time you headline, the next
time you headline.
No, I call it POIs.
I'm getting the POI out there.
Next time you have an idea.
Next time you have an idea, go against that idea as well.
Oh, no, what the?
Every idea I have, just make it the opposite.
that is insane i can't believe the headliner got bullied out
of their po i that is insane
to be fair it's good that we got it you know it's good that
we finally got team practice you know 100 without a doubt
because if we did it before challenges circuit i think it
would have been even worse wait what are we playing for
challenges circuit i mean listen let's My brain is fried
after these six games.
I can build the IG.
I just told us to get in three-man Trident and boosted the
fight night.
I mean, if I really capable of IG only, I didn't want this
player out.
Okay, but also remember where you took us before we were in
the Trident.
That was even, that was good.
We were, I think we were safe down there.
I did too.
If the zone pulled off, we were good.
I did not feel safe.
I 100%.
I mean, if we just had a fucking beacon.
I did not feel safe at all.
One time we had to...
Do you understand that in order to get a beacon today, we
just had to send Tempo over to Harvestor?
That was the only time we had a beacon.
We just dropped a literal manager of an esports team solo at
a POI to get a beacon.
We didn't even get a single beacon.
That's actually crazy.
That is crazy.
All six games, we had zero beacons.
We just played this game on a hard difficulty, literally
veteran mode.
I'm gonna fucking mac again, god damn it.
Fuck me.
That's actually insane.
That's insane.
We had one game of beacon, right?
What was it?
No, we didn't.
We had to walk over to the beacon.
Oh, no, no.
We had one in Jurassic.
Oh, yeah, Jurassic, yeah.
One out of five, baby.
One out of five.
Didn't we get fucked over in Jurassic still?
No, we didn't.
We did pretty well.
We just needed a cat wall.
We would have made like top five.
Yeah.
that's my bad yeah we had a you know what in the end we we
were we had a good bye honestly i actually had so much fun i
was glad we weren't last just wait wait guys we're better
than reptar yeah we're not last in the end reptar was rank
one last season in the in the end oh my god our team did
better than him you're so right we we technically we
technically beat the 25 yeah we're tech we're we beat rank
one pred um as a plaque team just remember that that's what
i'm saying hey full well no time about your platinum mario
what you're in platinum right now yeah i see a full platinum
squad yeah better than yeah full platinum squad the better
than that's our win that is our win today oh i know that is
the only thing i'm taking home with pride today better than
reptar i know greek i know greek needs a shot of alcohol so
bad right now the fact that greek lost to us oh and just
also if he's getting 20th then he didn't have a vibe squad
like us oh boy oh boy yeah yeah he didn't get to have the
fun part he didn't take a trident into a full team wait dude
come on man he had no idea there was a team there
so fast I didn't even know what happened I did things were
going to be bad because the moment the one the thing you
said was I'm gonna do something that might not be a good
idea but it'll be really funny that's what you said I mean I
sent you alone to 1v3 fistfight inside of fight night that's
pretty funny you were getting your ass beat inside of fight
night 1v3
at least at least we got the content out There's no way.
We got real content.
We had real content.
No other team had as much fun as us.
Who is this winning right now?
I don't know.
This team winning might have a good time.
They just wasted all their grenades.
They're not even pushing over it.
Why did they just waste all their grenades?
This is the watch party.
This is your watch party, Tad.
Exactly.
Look, Wig wanted to die early so he could watch party.
In-game watch party.
Yeah, here you go, Chad.
Look at that.
And the win is going to go.
Going on.
Nice.
Wow, look at that end game.
Wow.
Oh my god, who won?
I might be, I might be Jen.
Jen Burton, I think.
Oh, Jen, yeah, Jen won.
Wait, do you actually memorize the skins?
Wasn't he like first place by like 30 points going on this?
Yeah.
So did he just win by like 50 points?
Like 100 points?
Holy shit, with girl too.
Girls went crazy.
Man, I wonder what that's like.
That was not us, guys.
I wonder what that's like.
feel that yo we will challenge your circuit i don't think
we'll ever know what that feels like we got fucking rich
guys don't worry look at where team 14 is good we're safe
they didn't we would have been worrying if they got some
yeah yeah don't worry they had zero kills wait how does team
20 have three kills and they died in 20th i don't know they
wait what they wait what yeah what the maybe they res maybe
they res they could have got picks and then the the people
res maybe we did it guys guys what did we get man we had to
get last no we're your second last because because greece
team never got a single point oh everyone everyone gets the
same amount yeah everyone gets 400 11th to 20th all get same
amount okay yeah so we're fine it doesn't matter what
technically
11 place yeah yeah yeah everybody is 11 place so like
technically technically we're all 11 place except for greek
who's 12.
what apparently the team above us in docs was greek i was
probably i'm asking they were probably so confused why we
took the trident left they were probably so dumbfounded that
is unbelievable there's no fucking way he's probably like
they're taking the fucking trident that's so funny look at
us look at us go i told you guys i told you guys i bet you
no one had as much fun as us chad this was very good
practice yep challenger circuit agreed yo okay so what did
we learn today that we're gonna take it to challenger
circuit i think never get beacon so don't bother with a
controller okay that was not what we learned thank god you
understand what we learned today thank god we are talking
about this now what we learned that's exactly what we
learned what we learned is that we need a poi with a scan we
need we need to figure out a poi and even we're gonna get
contested we need we still need to figure out a poi and not
get bullied out of our poi unlike today like and we need to
figure out what to play because apparently we might be
playing this game for seven hours on saturday yep seven
hours of that we need to do better than that yeah and it's
going to be next week for sure right is it actually next
week or did i just gaslight you two thinking yeah i know
it's next week okay okay it's actually next week okay hey
hey oh my god bro your fucking chat wig i can see why tempo
is the manager not who said that wait a minute i have mud oh
no wait no i know right oh yeah 100 oh my chat my chat's
crazy right now yeah yeah i got shit on more today than i
ever have my life to be honest my chat are you gonna be
interviewed because Oh, hell no, I was already interviewed.
Girl's gonna get interviewed now.
What the fuck?
Are you gonna be interviewed?
We lost.
We should be having an interview for like the vibes.
I can't believe.
I can't believe we didn't get...
I can't believe you didn't bring us to the interview.
I can't.
Yeah, they should get you on there.
No, they should have got all of us.
What was your own strategy today getting 19 placed?
Well, nice week told me three times to take a trident when I
shouldn't have.
And, you know, he denied you all correctly one time.
We had a good time today.
Yeah.
He said, like, this was the last thing I heard was, this
might be a really bad idea, but it's going to be funny.
Yeah.
He said, this is going to be funny.
And then none of us laughed afterwards.
And then we got Arc started.
I got confused.
I got so confused.
I didn't know what was going on.
All I know is I got stunned.
And then there was people.
Temple had a bladder issue too.
so like honestly we should negate everything that happened
yeah we should just we should just reset the scores oh my
god reset and then multiply game one by six i don't think
game one was the game that we did the best in it was the
game four yeah yeah we know we got like we got three maps
out of six huh they won three games out of six jen bernstein
jen's team yeah that's fucking crazy bro that could have
been me if I was Jen picked me you guys really got every
game if Jen got you he loses 6 out of 6 there's no way we
should do it we should have like a control group here Jen
every tournament Jen will pick one of us and then see who
plays is higher it's not going to be me you're at your place
higher than me sadly we got to experiment here see who's
right that was so fucking fun man they are so much i
appreciate y'all playing too seriously guys that was really
fun that was that was let's play maybe just fucking maybe
play some game soon or something like that if you guys want
to actually like ranked we should really we should really
practice we should probably play a bit you guys want to
practice this week i'm down yeah yeah yeah all right yeah
what okay this week yeah yeah yeah yeah okay should it be
next week since cc's next week oh that's well yeah that's
what i meant like monday my bad oh Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, isn't today Monday?
What?
Today is.
Today is Friday.
Is what?
What?
Yeah, it's Friday.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, what's...
Oh, wait.
Did you not think it was Friday?
I forgot what day it was.
What?
Tempo, how do you run shit so, so efficiently, but just
don't even know the day of the week?
You're impressive, man.
I actually love you so much.
You're, like, the most functional, unfunctional person I
remember my life.
I'm not kidding.
Oh, yeah.
Have you seen, like, have you seen, like, all the, like, all
of his, like, his PC setup?
He has, like, five monitors or some shit.
Yeah, it's like he's like, and then Doki plastered all of
her merch.
Okay, not me.
All over my screens.
One of my patents.
She's like, here you go.
You should buy all of this Doki merch.
Buy Doki merch.
His walls are so bare.
You see these walls.
Also, wait, you promised me you would buy like a doki print
and put it on your backdrop.
I promise you I'd buy it and then burn it.
You said you would put it behind you.
I'll get it behind you and I'll put it behind me and I'll
burn it.
All right, do it.
Do it.
All right, deal.
Deal.
Do it.
It's just your money.
Yeah, I took my money.
It's just a picture of you.
It's literally your money.
Oh, yeah.
Speaking of subs.
how many do you deserve tempo what does the sub count wait
how many kills do we get tempo got four kills oh my god so
that's 40 subs more kills five subs per kill now oh yeah so
20 subs 20 subs i don't think tempo right yeah tempo
definitely not and then 20 no you said 20 subs for me and
you just keep bumping up the number yeah yeah i'll do it
yeah wait i can't give tempo subs wait what are you not even
an affiliate tempo no i can't i can't i was gonna be like
all right 20 gifted the tempo wait gift one seven i'm gonna
get 20 okay 20 subs is a hundred dollars yeah we got five
kills yeah you got five you got five we have five kills oh
we have five kills i don't know who guys i have an interview
with the winners i have no idea what's going on can we join
i i'm ah okay watch out i'll ask them to i'll i'll try to
get you guys in there we'll just be like hey we're gonna be
here to help in true we just like it crashed the interview
interview yeah by the way temple i made up that number i
don't even know how many kills you got yeah i don't know how
many kills we got i just made up total kills as five so okay
so so four i will we'll say with five we'll say He doesn't
know.
It says total kills.
He doesn't know.
It's okay.
He's not gonna fact check.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So five kills, right?
That's 25 subs for you.
It's payday.
Okay, we're back.
What is Wade gonna do?
Review the VOD?
Exactly.
She's not gonna review the VOD.
guys i don't think i don't think wig's gonna i don't think
he's coming back i don't think he's coming back guys i i
think he's gonna come back but the interview is gonna be
over he didn't bring us back to the room i can't believe it
i can't believe he didn't bring us into the interview room
he left us that's so fucked up he's about to he's about to
oh he's about to interview now that's fucked up he didn't
even tell us he didn't he didn't drag us in he didn't drag
us in Oh my god He actually just went Peace And left us I'm
gonna I'm gonna message him Shake my head actually left us
What Shake my head Can't believe it He left for milk
He actually left us We're like the only one Oh wait, no,
actually, I was going to say I thought we were like the only
one in VC But we can only see our own VCs
Yeah, and then the one above us We can click We can click
into the Oh no, wait, never mind, it's like We can't click
Wait, it is like Guys, we doubled We doubled Greek score Do
we double Greek score?
Guys, we doubled the week's score.
We doubled his score.
Guys, we did it.
We're better than the rank one Pred last season.
Just remember that.
Any team.
We're better than the team that was the Hatter rank one
Pred.
That's all it takes.
Oh my god.
Look, last look.
It's because the current season doesn't have rank one yet.
We don't know who's the current rank one pred yet this
season.
We don't know.
We don't know, so it doesn't matter, chat.
Yeah, because it hasn't ended yet.
We're the God's strongest plan.
No, it didn't.
What do you mean?
The season's still ongoing.
Is rank season still ongoing?
It ends next week.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's still ongoing.
Okay, so we're good.
We're good.
We're good to go.
You know, I think we did pretty well.
I think we did pretty well as a team.
I had zero expectations.
I still have zero expectations, but...
I thought we were going to get in the middle.
I know it wasn't going to happen.
I know.
I mean, with our POIs, there was no way.
Like, literally, we had zero good POIs.
We literally got kicked out of all the good POIs.
the last twitch rivals we did we actually had decent places
to land we actually had let's see that's true let's yeah we
were we were what grow towers we had loot yeah we had actual
loot and we weren't getting contested this time we we got
contested every time or not even down we we got kicked out
of our areas where is poi it's like um i forgot what was the
abbreviation for poi the landmarks so where you're landing i
don't know what the abbreviation is i forgot point of
interest oh poi point of interest so it's basically where
teams get to pick where you want to land the landmarks and
stuff and then um we try to pick good spots but then every
other team kicked us out every team kicked us out of the the
spots so all so we got the spots that were considered like
absolutely trash loot with zero with zero hope he's weak
he's a little bitch oh
my god this i don't even know how long this interview is
gonna be how long is this interview it just started wait
they just started the interview yeah oh no they i oh my god
they just started the interview oh my god i can't believe it
how long are we gonna be waiting here
Yeah, the interview just started now.
Okay, if this interview is going to take really, really,
really long, I might peace out soon.
I think it takes like 15.
15 minutes?
Alright, GG's tempo.
Tell Wig that I couldn't wait 15 minutes.
I couldn't wait.
GG's.
Okay, wait.
I have zero patience.
All right, Gigi's Tempo.
You have to do your schedule, right?
Yeah, I have to do my schedule.
When did you want to play?
What do you mean?
When did you want to play, right?
I mean, most likely I won't be streaming it because I also
have another Apex tournament, too, other than CC.
So I don't want to put too many Apex on.
I'll most likely just play off, like, you guys can stream,
but I'll play off stream.
Okay.
All right, Gigi's Tempo.
You mean the one tomorrow, right?
What?
No, not that.
Next week.
I mean, next week I have a lot.
I have another, I have two, another Apex tournament other
than the CC one.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
okay yeah it's not been announced yet so i can't really see
much about it oh okay gotcha yeah yeah ggs bye i'll see you
next i'll see you tomorrow yeah i'll see you tomorrow at
finals bye bye all right all right guys uh i'm gonna call it
here because like i actually i cannot wait 15 minutes i
don't want to watch i don't want to watch an interview for
15 minutes guys i don't want to watch it but i had a great
time i had a great time always love playing with wig and
tempo um we're just like around i i had very low
expectations and it's not last i'm fine with that i'm fine
we beat the rank one fred team that's fine with me i'm happy
with that the fact that we weren't last is good enough for
me it's good enough for me um but it was honestly it was
really fun um yeah exceeded my very very low expectations um
and i hope you guys had a fun time watching um uh if you're
new here i usually stream on the youtube's so please check
me out over there exclamation point socials to see all the
social social media stuff i have um for twitch streams um i
usually tweet tweet it out whenever i'm streaming on twitch
and so please follow me twitch updates uh what else what
else oh yes uh if you want to support me via other means
please check out my merch also we're twitch partner this is
my first twitch partner stream thank you everybody for
coming i hope you guys enjoyed the first twitch i've never
been twitch partner before this is the first time i've ever
been twitch partner thank you everyone i hope you guys had a
uh we guys had a fun time coming up to my very first twitch
partner stream uh thank you for all the gifted subs all the
bitties um all the donations all the follows i really really
really do appreciate it guys um as always everybody stay
hydrated posture check get up and move around to get that
blood flowing and if you stood up for me head to bed because
you deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody bye
guys bye